blazer web assembly is a single page app
framework for building interactive
client-side web apps with net it uses
open web standards without plug-ins or
recompiling code into other languages
this course will teach you how to use
blazer web assembly and web api on.net
6. you will learn step by step how to
build a shopping cart application this
course also provides a guide on how to
integrate a payment gateway into your
blazer webassembly component so that a
user is able to pay for products through
your application using a debit or credit
card or even a paypal account
gavin lawn teaches this course
gavin is a senior software engineer with
over 20 years of experience i encourage
you to leave a comment with the most
interesting thing you learn for the
benefit of other campers who are
watching this course
please join me as we build a very basic
shopping cart application using blazer
webassembly
a few of the significant technologies
we'll use for building our application
are as follows
the latest version of visual studio
which is visual studio 2022
and we'll use the community edition for
windows
dot net 6 which is at the time of
creating this video the latest version
of dot net it was released in november
of 2021
sql server 2019
laser web assembly we'll use bootstrap
version 5 for layout and styling
purposes we'll build a restful mvc web
api project for handling database
related functionality and returning
relevant data from the server to our
client side blazer application
all technologies used for the
development of this application can be
downloaded free of charge please see
below in the description the locations
of where you are able to download the
relevant technologies for free we are
going to integrate a payment gateway
powered by paypal into our application
so that a user can use their paypal
account or a valid debit or credit card
to pay for the items that are purchased
through our online shopping cart
application
blazer is a relatively new feature of
asp.net
it offers two hosting models a
server-side hosting model and a
client-side hosting model
we are going to use the client-side
hosting model for the development of our
shopping cart application the
significance of this hosting model is
that the c-sharp code runs directly
within our browsers
what makes this possible is a technology
named webassembly
in recent years the creation of spa
applications or single page applications
have become very popular as web
solutions
up until fairly recently javascript
frameworks like angular or react have
been the available choices for the
creation of spa applications
with blazer we are now able to create
our single page applications using
c-sharp
we don't necessarily need to depend on
javascript for the creation of our
interactive ui code
we can create this code using c-sharp
in this application however the payment
gateway provided by paypal is coded in
javascript
so we will use blaze's interoperability
functionality with javascript to
interact with the relevant javascript
paypal code
so let's get started
let's create our blazer solution
let's fire up visual studio 2022
select create new project
let's choose the appropriate project
template
blazer webassembly app
let's name our solution shop online
solution
let's name the blazer project
shoponline.web
great
let's add a new project to our solution
where we'll create our restful web api
functionality
so let's ensure that we choose the
correct project template
let's name our project shoponline.api
notice that for the authentication type
we are choosing none
we are not going to implement membership
functionality which of course includes
login and registration functionality
we'll focus purely on the shopping cart
functionality
we want to run our application on the
latest version
of.net.net 6.
note that we have enabled open api
support by doing this the swashbuckle
nuget package will be automatically
installed and the appropriate swagger
middleware will be automatically
configured appropriately within our
project
one of the advantages of this is when we
run our web api project interactively
we'll be able to test our web api code
through our browsers even before we have
developed any front-end code
so a basic ui will automatically be
created for this purpose for us
when we run our application
interactively we'll be able to test each
of our action methods through the
relevant automatically created web-based
ui
note that you can also use a tool like
postman to test your web api
functionality
i won't be using postman during the
development of this application
we are going to build our database using
codefirst migrations and entity
framework core
migrations allow us to evolve our
database without losing data or database
objects
so by using plain old c-sharp classes we
can build the database entities that we
wish to include within our shopping cart
application
once we have created relevant related
c-sharp classes we'll look at an entity
relationship diagram that represents our
shopping cart applications database
design
let's add a folder named entities to our
project this is where the classes that
will represent our database entities
will reside
so let's create a class named cart to
represent the cart entity
so let's add two public properties to
this class
id as integer and user id as integer
let's add a new class named cart item
this entity represents an item that has
been added to the user's shopping cart
so let's add an integer property named
id
let's add an integer property named cart
id
this property represents a foreign key
field
and is used to join the cart entity to
the cart item entity
so the cart entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the cart item entity
this denotes that many card items can be
included within one particular shopping
cart
let's include an integer property named
product id
lastly let's include an integer property
named qty
representing the quantity or number of a
particular product that may be included
within a particular shopping cart
let's create a new class representing
the product entity
the product entity will have a
one-to-many relationship with the cart
item entity this denotes that a product
can be included many times across many
different shopping carts
let's add an integer property named id
let's add a string property named name
let's add a string property named
description
let's add a string property named image
url
let's create a property of type decimal
named price
let's create a property of type integer
named qty
lastly let's add a property of type
integer named category id
the categoryid property represents a
foreign key from the product category
entity the code for which we are about
to implement
so let's create a class named product
category
this entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the product entity
let's add a public property named id
note that when a property is named id
by convention entity framework core will
designate the id property as
representative of the relevant entity's
primary key
let's add a property of type string and
name this property name
and lastly let's create a class to
represent our user entity which of
course represents a user of our
application
note that i've included this entity as a
temporary substitute for a membership
facility like for example microsoft
identity so that we can focus on the
shopping cart workflows and not be
distracted by the membership
functionality so let's add an integer
property named id
let's add a string property named
username
so if we look at this entity
relationship diagram we can see the
relationships between our entities
the cart entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the cart item entity
the product entity has a one-to-many
relationship with the card item entity
the product category entity has a
one-to-many relationship with the
product entity
the user entity has a one-to-one
relationship with the cart entity
so this basically means each user can
only have one shopping cart within our
application
if you look at the sql server management
studio that is installed on my local
machine you can see that i've already
generated a database through ef core
this was done when i was developing the
prototype for this application
so we are now going to use efcor to
generate a database for our shopping
cart application
the classes that we have just created
representing our entities
will be used by ef core to generate the
corresponding database tables within a
database that ef core will create for us
in order to generate our database with
the relevant tables through visual
studio
let's install two nuget packages
to do this right click the dependencies
node within our shoponline.api project
click the manage new get packages menu
item
click the browse tab on the new get
package manager dialog
let's search for entity framework core
dot sql server
and this is the package we want to
install
let's click the install button
then the i accept button
great
let's search for the second package that
we need to install the reason we are
installing this package is because we
want to run our migrations from within
visual studio as opposed to using
the.net cli for this purpose
note that you would use different
commands when running migration commands
using the.net cli as opposed to the
commands you would run when using visual
studio
so let's search for entity framework
call dot tools
and this is the package we want
let's install the microsoft dot entity
framework core dot tools nuget package
the next step is we must configure a
connection string in order to connect
our application with the database that
we wish to create using entity framework
core code first migrations
so let's open the appsettings.json file
within our shoponline.web project
within the connection string that i'm
configuring here
i'm including my server name which is
gavin lon's pc
the database which i wish to name shop
online
and we are going to use a trusted
connection to connect our shopping cart
applications web api to our database so
let's include trusted underscore
connection equals true within our
connection string
note that i have named my connection
string shop online connection
let's create our database context class
let's first create a folder named data
within our shoponline.api
project
let's add a class named shoponlinedb
context to our new data folder
so in order to make this class represent
our ef core database context we need to
implement code so that our shop online
db context class
inherits from ef course db context class
you can see there's a red squiggly line
under db context this is because we
haven't yet brought in the microsoft dot
entity framework call namespace
an easy way to include the appropriate
using directive through visual studio
is to press control period and then
select the appropriate menu item from
the menu that is presented to us through
visual studio
let's create the constructor for our
shop online dbcontext class
we must add a parameter to the
constructor that we have just generated
the parameter is named options
and is of the generic type db context
options which has the data type shop
online db context passed as an argument
to it
we can then write code to pass the
argument that will be passed to our shop
online db context class constructor to
the base class from which it inherits
i.e the db context class
now because i want to focus on the
shopping cart workflows at this stage
and don't want us to be distracted by
the implementation of administrative
crowd operation functionality
we are going to seed our database with
certain data
this is data that i've already prepared
so we are not going to include create
read update and delete functionality
regarding the creation and maintenance
of product data at this stage we are
going to seed our database with product
related data
we are going to seed our database with
the relevant data so that we can move
directly to the creation of our shopping
cart functionality
so in order to seed the database
appropriately we can override a method
that exists within the db context base
class
this method is named on model creating
an easy way to generate the relevant
override code for this method through
visual studio is to type in the word
override and then press the spacebar we
can then select the on model creating
item from the drop-down list presented
to us within visual studio
i have already prepared the code for
seeding our database and this code can
be found at this location on github
so let's go to the appropriate github
location
and copy this code to our clipboards
let's then paste the code from our
clipboards into the on model creating
method
the next step
is to let entity framework core know as
it were about our entities
so we can do this by using the entity
framework call dbset generic type
so for each of our entities we need to
appropriately include a public property
of type db set
within our shop online dbcontext class
to register our shop online db context
class for dependency injection let's
open the
relevantprogram.cs file
then we can simply add this code here to
register our shop online dbcontext class
for dependency injection
note that our code is reading the
connection string that we configured in
the app settings.json file
we are now ready to generate a migration
using ef core
so let's launch the new get package
console manager window from within
visual studio like this
we can then type the appropriate command
to generate a migration
so let's type in add dash migration
followed by the name of the migration we
wish to create
so when i run the add dash migration
command i get an exception
i've found out that this exception
occurred because at present the
shoponline.web project
is set to my startup project within the
relevant solution
so if you get this exception all you
need to do to fix this is make the
shoponline.api project your startup
project like this
so let's try again
and now we don't get the exception and
it works as expected
and you can see code within the up
method of the migration class that we
have just generated
this code creates our database and the
relevant tables
this method also contains code that
seeds the relevant database tables with
the data that i prepared prior to
creating this video
the down method contains code to undo
the changes made by code contained
within the up method
to run our migration all we need to do
is type the update database command
within the new get package manager
console window like this
and then of course press enter
and now if we look at sql server
management studio we can see that the
shop online database has been created
the database tables have been
appropriately created based on the
entities we created using c-sharp
classes
the relevant database tables have been
seeded with the data created from the
code we included within the on model
creating method
which resides within the shop online db
context class
the data with which we have seeded our
database contains product and user
information
this has been done so that we can focus
on the shopping cart functionality and
not worry at this stage about
implementing code or create read update
and delete functionality regarding
products sold by our fictional online
store
here are just a few notes about running
migrations
please note that if you have run a
migration or more than one migration and
are not happy with the changes made to
the database
you can undo the changes made by running
this command update dash database
followed by a zero
the number zero is a special case that
means before the first migration and
causes the effects of all migrations to
be rolled back
you may wish to remove the migrations
after this you can remove a migration
that has not yet been used to update the
database
by running the command remove dash
migration
the remove dash migration command will
remove the last migration that has not
yet run
note that if for example you have
updated the database with multiple
migrations
and you wish to roll back the changes to
before a particular migration was run
you can roll back your changes
to that particular state
by running the migration that was run
directly before the migrations that were
run that contain the changes you wish to
roll back
this is the second part in a series of
videos dedicated to building a shopping
cart application
using blazer and a restful web api
in this video we are going to start with
the workflow that involves retrieving
product data from our database
and returning the data to the client
blazer component
the code for this functionality will be
implemented within a web api component
so in this tutorial we'll start to
develop our web api component
before we do this
let's create the classes that represent
the data that will be passed between the
web api component and the blazer
component
you might be thinking but we have
already created the classes to represent
the data for our application for example
product product category cart cart item
etc yes we did create these classes that
represent our entities in the previous
part of this video series
these entity classes directly map to the
database tables that were generated when
we ran the relevant migration
the function of these classes can be
seen as blueprints for their
corresponding database tables
when we pass data between the web api
component and the blazer component we
don't necessarily want to pass the exact
data defined by the properties in the
classes that represent the database
entities
for example in this tutorial we are
going to create code that returns the
product data from the web api component
to the blazer component
the product class contains certain
product related properties one of which
is the category id
a particular category id value
could for example denote
that a particular product falls under
the electronics category and could for
example be a laptop
or for example the product could fall
under the furniture category
and could be for example a couch
the category id property within the
product entity is a foreign key
from the product category entity
from a human perspective the category id
property does not have much meaning
because it contains a numeric value so
it wouldn't for example make much sense
to display the category id to the user
we may want to pass the relevant
category name in addition to the product
information defined in the product class
so to facilitate this we can create a
new model
that contains all the relevant products
data as well as the relevant category
name which is included in the product
category entity and not the product
entity
so it makes sense to create a new model
to represent the data
that in this case we wish to pass from
server to client
we need a model that includes all the
product information as well as the
category name
the type of model i am referring to is
known as a dto or data transfer object
this type of model includes the data
that needs to be passed between server
and client
so a dto is an object that defines how
the data will be sent over the network
the classes that represent our entities
that we created in the first tutorial
directly map to their corresponding
database tables
these classes represent the structure of
certain tables in our database
we can create dtos data transfer objects
that are based on the underlying entity
classes but may be differently shaped
based on the data that needs to be
passed between client and server
we are going to create a standard
library project to house our dtos
so let's create a new project within our
solution
let's select the appropriate class
library project template
let's name our new project
shoponline.models
let's delete the default class generated
for us by visual studio
let's create a folder named dtos
so let's create the dtos that we are
going to use in our application
now the only dto that we are interested
in at the moment will be named product
dto
but let's create the other dto classes
that will be used later on in the
development of our application as well
as the products dto class
the dto classes will be explained in
more detail at appropriate points during
the development of our application
let's create a class named cart item dto
let's make sure our new class contains
the public access modifier
let's create the properties for the cart
item dto class
id as integer
product id as integer
cart id as integer
product name as string
product description as string
product image url as string
price as decimal
total price as decimal
and qty as integer
let's create a new class named cart item
to add dto
let's ensure that our new class contains
the public access modifier
so cart id as integer product id as
integer and qty as integer
let's create a new class named cart item
qty update dto
let's ensure that our new class contains
the public access modifier
cart item id as integer
qty as integer
let's create a class named product dto
this is the dto that we are going to use
in this tutorial
let's ensure that our new class contains
the public access modifier
id as integer name as string description
as string
image url as string
price as decimal
qty as integer
category id as integer and category name
as string
great so we have created the classes
that represent our dtos data transfer
objects
let's go to our shop online.api project
so we are now going to start coding the
logic for our first workflow starting
with the web api component
this workflow simply involves retrieving
product data from our database and
returning the data to the client blazer
application the blazer application will
contain code that displays the relevant
product data to the user
so now our shop online db context class
has been registered for dependency
injection
we'll see in a bit how we are able to
implement code to ensure that an object
of type shop online db context is
injected into relevant classes
we are going to use the repository
design pattern to abstract our data
handling layer
repositories are classes or components
that encapsulate the logic required to
access data sources
we can use repositories to centralize
common data access functionality
which has the benefit of facilitating
better maintainability easier unit
testing
extensibility and cleaner code
the best way to understand the
repository pattern is to implement the
relevant code
so let's write the code for our product
repository functionality
so let's create a folder named
repositories
within the repositories folder let's
create a folder named contracts
within the contracts folder let's create
an interface named i product repository
let's create four method definitions
within our new interface
we want all these methods to run
asynchronously so all the method
definitions within this interface will
return generic task objects
our first method is named getitems and
returns an i enumerable collection of
type product
so the i enumerable collection is passed
as a type argument
to the task object
as discussed
this is so the method that implements
this method definition
can run asynchronously
the other methods follow a similar
pattern
let's define the method definition for a
method named get categories
let's define a method definition for a
method named get item which contains a
parameter of type integer named id
let's define a method definition for a
method named get category which contains
a parameter of type integer named id
so we have defined the interface
that we want a class named product
repository to implement
so let's create a class directly within
the repositories directory named product
repository
and the first thing we need to do is
write the code to implement the i
product repository interface so let's do
that
we can see a red squiggly line under i
product repository
this is because we need to bring in the
shoponline.api.repositories.contracts
namespace
a quick way to do this is press ctrl
period and then select the appropriate
item from a list provided by visual
studio like this
the red squiggly line is still there
this is because visual studio is telling
us as it were
that we need to implement code for all
the method definitions that we have
defined within the i product repository
interface
so let's press ctrl period once again
and select the appropriate item from the
list presented to us
and visual studio generates the relevant
code stubs for us
so visual studio generates default
implementations for
the relevant method definitions
so at this stage we only want to
implement the code logic relevant to the
workflow that is the focus of this video
i.e returning a collection of product
data to the client side calling code in
this case our blazer component
we are going to need to use the shop
online db context object to interact
with our shop online database
as you will recall earlier
we registered the shop online db context
object for dependency injection
this means that we are able to gain
access to an object of type shop online
db context by defining an appropriate
parameterized constructor in our product
repository class
so let's create the code for this
an easy way to automatically generate a
constructor within visual studio
is type ctor
and then press the tab key twice like
this
then in order to indicate to.net that we
want an object of type shop online db
context to be injected into this
constructor all we need to do is define
a parameter within our constructor of
type shop online db context like this
let's bring in the appropriate namespace
and we can get visual studio to create
an appropriate private read-only member
variable to reference our shop online db
context object
by pressing control period
and selecting the appropriate item from
the list presented to us by visual
studio
great
so for the workflow that is the focus of
this tutorial
we only need to implement code for two
of the method definitions within the i
product
repository interface
so at this point we are only going to
implement code for the get items method
and the get categories method
so let's implement code for the get
items method
all we want this method to do is return
all the products from the products table
so let's write the code for this
note we want our code to run
asynchronously so we must include the
await keyword here
notice how once we have typed in the
await keyword that the async keyword
automatically appears in the method
definition for the get items method
if you include the await keyword within
a method
the method in which you include the
await keyword must appropriately contain
the async keyword
note that to include the to list async
extension method here in our code we
must bring in the microsoft.entity
framework core namespace
and that's it
we have written the code to return an i
enumerable collection of products data
from our database
so let's implement the code to return
the product categories from our database
we can do this by implementing the
appropriate code within our get
categories method like this
great
so we have now implemented the code for
retrieving product data from our
database
the next step is to write code to return
the appropriate data to the calling
client
so to do this we need to create an
appropriate controller class
before we create our controller class
let's delete these classes that were
generated by default when we first
created our web api project
these classes are obviously not going to
be used in our application
so now let's create a class within our
controllers directory
let's ensure that we select the
appropriate controller class template
let's name this class product controller
so the first thing to do is to write the
code so that an object of type product
repository is automatically injected
into our controller classes constructor
via dependency injection
let's also ensure that we have a
read-only private field that references
the object passed in via dependency
injection
but we haven't yet registered our
product repository class for dependency
injection
so let's write the code for this let's
open the program.cs file
let's implement the code to register the
product repository class with the
dependency injection system
notice how we use the add scoped method
to register our product repository class
for dependency injection
we could have used the add transient
method or the add singleton method to
register our product repository class
with the dependency injection system but
in our case add scoped is the
appropriate method for this purpose
very basically
using add transient would mean that a
new instance of the relevant object is
provided to every class that requires
the relevant object to be injected
using add singleton would mean that the
same instance of the object is injected
into the relevant classes for every http
request
using add scoped means that the same
instance of the object is injected into
relevant classes within a particular
http request
note that in this case a new instance of
the relevant object will be created for
each http request
let's create a method definition for an
action method named get items
we want our action method to run
asynchronously
the type that is passed to the generic
task object
is of the generic action result type
one of the core benefits of returning an
action result
is that as well as returning the
requested data from an action method to
the client an appropriate response
status code can also be returned for
example a http status code of 200 means
the request
has succeeded a status code of 404
represents that a resource could not be
found and a http status code of 500
represents that an internal server error
occurred
so we need to pass the type of data that
we wish to return to the client as a
type argument to the action result
generic type
so we want to return an i enumerable
collection of type product dto to the
client
so the first thing we need to do is
create a project reference to the shop
online dot models project
because this is where our product dto
class resides
then let's bring in the
shoponline.models.dtos namespace great
let's name our action method get items
each action method in our controller
must map to a particular http verb
for example get post push delete etc
our get items action method will be used
for getting product data and returning
that product data to the client
so the appropriate http verb for this
action method is get
so to indicate this to dot net we need
to decorate our get items action method
with the http get attribute
so let's implement the code logic for
our get items action method
let's first create a try catch block
an easy way to do this in visual studio
is to type in try followed by pressing
the tab key twice
so let's write code that calls the
product repository classes get items
method asynchronously to return an i
enumerable collection of type product to
our action method
we want to include the category name
associated with each product in our
collection so let's write code to return
a collection
of product category objects to our
action method
we'll write the code that joins our
collection of products with our
collection of product categories in a
bit
so you may have spotted that the code in
this action method is not ideal at the
moment
it is not ideal because we are
retrieving a collection of products and
a collection of categories in two
separate queries to the database
a more performant way for retrieving the
product collection and related category
data
would be to appropriately use the
include extension method
within the relevant link query in the
get items method within the product
repository class
the use of the include method would join
the data retrieved from the products
database table with related data
retrieved from the product categories
database table and allow for the
products data and related category data
to be returned through one query
i'm going to leave the code as it is for
now we'll optimize this code for
performance by using the include
extension method as i've just described
toward the end of the course
so if either the products variable is
null
or the product categories variable is
null
let's return a status code of not found
to the calling client code
so in this case our web api will return
a http status code of 404
meaning that relevant data was not found
or a relevant resource was not found
so in this case it means that the client
request failed
and the reason for the failure is that
an essential resource could not be found
else
we want to join the collection of
product categories with the collection
of products so that we can return a
collection of product dtos to the
calling client code
which will include the category name
remember the product dto definition
contains a category name property
in order to get the category name for
each product in the collection we need
to join the collection of type product
to the collection of type product
category
we are going to use link for this
purpose
in order to avoid creating too many
lines of code within our action method
we are going to create an extension
method to return a collection type of
product dto to our action method
so let's create a folder named
extensions
let's create a class within our
extensions folder named dto conversions
note that in order to create an
extension method we need the class that
houses our extension methods to be
static
let's create our extension method
so the extension method must be a static
method and we want to return an
ienumerable collection of objects of
type product dto to the calling code
let's name our method convert to dto
the first parameter in an extension
method must be the type of an object on
which we want
to be able to call the convert dto
extension method so by convention this
parameter definition must also be
preceded by this keyword
so on an ienumerable collection of type
product we want to be able to call the
convert to dto method in order to
convert an ienumerable collection of
type product to an ienumerable
collection of type product dto
the logic for this method will using a
link query join a collection of type
product to a collection of type product
category and return a collection of type
product dto to the calling code so the
second parameter of the convert to dto
method is of a type that is an
ienumerable collection of type product
category
let's write the logic for our extension
method
so let's write a link query that joins
the collection of type product to the
collection of type product category and
return a collection of type product dto
great
so let's go back to the product
controller class and finish the code for
the get items action method
so in order for the convert to dto
method to be accessible on the products
variable
we must of course bring in the
shoponline.api.extension's namespace
then let's pass in the product
categories variable as an argument to
the convert to dto extension method
then we can return
a http status code of 200 to the calling
code
we can do this by returning the results
of an ok method
which accepts an argument of a
collection of type
product dto
so this code returns a http status code
of 200
as well as a collection of type product
dto to the calling client code
so if for some reason an exception
occurs during the running of the
relevant server side code
in this case we want our code
to return a http status code of 500
to the calling client code coupled with
an appropriate error message
let's keep the error message simple
great
so if we open our program.cs file
you can see the configuration code here
related to swagger and swagger ui
swagger is an interface description
language
for describing restful apis expressed
using json
the configuration relevant to swagger ui
here means that our web api project is
equipped with a basic web-based user
interface
where we can see relevant information
regarding our controllers and action
methods
we are also able to use the swagger user
interface to test and debug our action
methods
when we run our web api code
interactively through visual studio
so let's run our code to see this in
action
and here we are presented with the
swagger ui
let's test our get items action method
we can do this through our swagger user
interface like this
excellent
in the next part of this video series
we'll write the calling client code that
calls the action method that we have
written in this tutorial from our blazer
component
we'll also write the code to
appropriately display the products
returned from our web api component to
the user
so in the next tutorial we'll start to
develop our blazer webassembly component
so this is the third part of a video
series where we are building a shopping
cart application using blazer web
assembly and web api
we are building our application on.net 6
which at the time of writing this video
is the latest version of net
we are now at a stage
where we have built our database using
entity framework core code first
migrations
and have started implementing code for
the first workflow which simply involves
retrieving products data from our
database and displaying this product's
data to the user
in part 2 the previous part of this
video series
we implemented the code that retrieves
the relevant product data from our
database and returns the data to the
calling client
this code was implemented in an action
method within a controller class named
product controller
this class was created within our
shoponline.api project which contains
the code for our web api component
in this video we want to start
developing the code for our client-side
blazer component
so in this video we'll implement code
within our blazer component to call the
action method that we developed in the
previous part of this video series and
display the returned data to the user
so let's get started
the first thing we need to do is copy
the url to our clipboards which is the
url of our web api component
when we run the shoponline.api project
through visual studio
we are doing this so that we can
appropriately configure our blazer
component to point to the appropriate
local web api url
so that we can easily test our
application through visual studio during
the development phase of our shopping
cart application
one way we can access the relevant url
is to simply run our web api project
so let's copy this part of the url
which we can refer to as the base url or
base address to our clipboards
then let's open the program.cs class
within our shoponline.web component
so here is a block of code that was
automatically included within our
shoponline.web component
whereby the http client object is
configured for dependency injection
this means that we will automatically
have access to a http client object from
appropriately written classes within our
blazer component
we will be using the http client object
to call relevant action methods within
our web api component
so in order for our http client
component to point to the web api
component on our local machines we need
to replace the argument
that is currently being passed to the
uri constructor here with the base url
that we have just copied to our
clipboards
so let's appropriately paste the base
url copied to our clipboards here
great
so we are going to wrap the
functionality that handles calls to our
web api component within services
these services are simply c-sharp
classes that wrap the functionality for
handling
interactions with our web api component
so the first thing to do is create a
folder named services
then within the services folder let's
create a folder named contracts
let's create an interface named i
product service within the contracts
folder
so we'll build up the methods for the
product service class over time when
appropriate during the development of
our application
we are just going to implement code for
one method in this video
so let's create a method definition for
our method in the i product service file
we want our method to run asynchronously
so our method will return a task object
in this case we are going to write code
to return a generic task object
because this method must return a value
to the calling code
the type of value that we want to return
to calling code is an ienumerable
collection of objects of type product
dto
let's name this method get items
in a bit we'll implement code for this
method to retrieve relevant product data
from the appropriate action method that
resides within our web api component
we have a red squiggly line under
product dto
the product dto type is defined within
the shop online.models project so let's
create a project reference to the shop
online dot models project
let's then bring in the name space for
the product dto type
great
okay so let's create the code to
implement our i product service
interface
so let's create a class named product
service
directly within the services folder
let's create a constructor
so we want to tell dot net as it were
that we want a http client object to be
injected into our product service class
so to do this we simply define a
parameter of type http client within our
constructor definition
then let's generate a read-only member
variable
to reference the object of type http
client that will be injected into this
class at runtime
the next thing to do
is to implement the i product service
interface so let's write the code for
this
let's generate the code stub for the
method that we have defined within the i
product service interface
let's write the code logic for the get
items method
let's first generate a try catch block
within the try block let's write code to
call the get items action method
that resides within the product
controller of our web api component
you can see we are using the generic get
from json async method to call the
appropriate action method within our web
api component
we are passing in a type argument which
is an ienumerable collection of type
product dto to the get json async
generic method
we are doing this because we want our
get from json async method to return an
ienumerable collection of type product
dto
so this method will translate the data
which will be in json format
returned from the web api component into
an object of type i innumerable
which is strongly typed with the type
product dto
notice that we are passing in texture
which denotes where the collection of
resources that we want to retrieve from
our web api component can be found
the web api component will know as it
were to invoke the get items action
method within the product controller
class of our web api component based on
this information passed as an argument
to the get from json async method
we have a red squiggly line under get
from json async so to get rid of the
error flagged by the c-sharp compiler
we must bring in the system.net
dot http dot json namespace
this is where the get from json async
extension method resides
the get items action method that we are
calling in our web api component will
return a collection of objects of type
product dto in json format
the json data will automatically be
translated into an i enumerable
collection of objects of type product
dto for us
so our products variable here will
reference the returned result which will
be an ienumerable collection of objects
of type product dto
so we could add additional codes to
handle the http response returned from
the web api component
we'll look at writing code for this
when we look at exception handling in
more detail in a later tutorial
for now i just want to go through the
basics of returning data from the web
api component and displaying the data to
the user from code created within the
blazer web assembly component
so now we are going to create our razor
component where we will create the code
to display the data to the user i.e the
data returned from the service
functionality we have just created
razer components are fundamental to
blazer simply put
blazer apps are built using razer
components
so within the pages folder let's create
a razor component named products.razer
note that we are able to create our code
to call our service functionality
directly within our razer file within
the code section here
in the interests of creating cleaner
code we are going to abstract the code
for consuming our service functionality
within a base class
our raiser component will then inherit
from the appropriate base class
so let's create a c-sharp class named
products base
so in order for our base class to be
inherited from our razor component our
base class must inherit from a class
named component base which resides
within the
microsoft.asp.net core dot components
namespace
so let's go to our razer file
we want our products.razer component to
be invoked when our application is first
loaded
so we can ensure that this happens by
declaring information about our razor
components root at the top of this page
like this
note that when a razor component with an
at page directive is compiled
the generated component class is
provided a root attribute specifying the
component's root template
here we are just providing a forward
slash this means that when the url
contains only the base url for our
blazer component
that our products dot razor component
will be invoked
and now we can write code within our
razor file that declares that our
products.razer component inherits from
the product base class like this
so let's go back to our product space
class
let's create a property to facilitate
dependency injection
of an object of type i product service
into our products razor component
so let's define a public property of
type i product service named product
service
so to indicate to.net that we want an
object of type i product service
injected into this property we need to
decorate the appropriate property with
the inject attribute like this
and of course we mustn't forget to
register our product service class for
dependency injection
so to do this let's open the program.cs
class
and implement the relevant dependency
injection configuration code like this
great
let's create a public property to expose
an ienumerable collection of objects of
type product dto
this collection will be accessible to
the relevant razor code that we'll
implement in a bit
to output the product data
so now we want our code that retrieves
our product data from the server our web
api component to run when the product's
razor component is first invoked
we can do this by overriding a function
named uninitialized async
so to override a method we can type
override press the spacebar and then
select the method that we wish to
override
we want to override a method named on
initialized async so let's select the
appropriate item here
the on initialized async method is
associated with a blazer lifecycle event
let's read a little bit about lifecycle
events on this microsoft docs webpage
the razer component processes razer
component life cycle events in a set of
synchronous and asynchronous life cycle
methods
the life cycle methods can be overridden
to perform additional operations in
components during component
initialization and rendering
if the component is rendering for the
first time on a request
create the components instance
perform property injection run set
parameters async call
on initialized async
if an incomplete task is returned the
task is awaited and then the component
is rendered
so within the uninitialized async method
let's implement the code for retrieving
our products data from our web api
component like this
we are using the object of type i
product service that will be injected
into this class at runtime to return the
relevant products data to our product
component
let's implement code for outputting the
product data
so if the product property is null ie
has not yet been retrieved from the
server
we can output a loading indicator to the
user so while the data is being
retrieved
this loading indicator will remain on
the user's screen
else when the relevant product data has
populated the products property
we want code to execute that outputs the
product's data to the user in an
aesthetically pleasing style
let's bring in the namespace of our
product dto
class we can include this using
directive in the underscore
imports.raiser file here
and this means that this using directive
will apply to the other razer files as
well
let's write a link query here that
sequentially takes four items at a time
from the collection of product dto
objects
images relevant to each of the products
has been uploaded to github please feel
free to download these images each image
maps to a row of data in the products
table in our database we seeded our
database with the relevant data in the
first part of this video series
let's then implement code to
appropriately output the product data
bootstrap 5 is being used to output each
item of products data as a bootstrap
card
later we are going to abstract this code
further to clean up the code a bit
the final code for this functionality is
available on github
the appropriate link can be found below
in the description
for now i just want to write code to
display our product data appropriately
to the user
it was pointed out in the comments
section that my spelling of the word
furniture is incorrect both in the shop
online db context class and the sidebar
in the prototype shopping cart
application that i created in
preparation for this video series
i don't know why i spelled furniture
with an a like this
for nature
but clearly that's what i did
the consequence is that after you ran
the migration to create and seed your
database the word furniture may be
incorrectly spelt in your product
database table and your products
category database table
of course you may have spotted this and
fixed this before creating and running
the relevant migration if not the good
news is that this is easy to fix
i thought that fixing this issue gives
us a great opportunity to see how easy
it is to fix issues like this during the
development phase of our application
using ef core migrations
we can fix the relevant data simply by
correcting the spelling issue within the
on model creating method in the shop
online dbcontext class
we can then generate a migration that
will contain the code that can be used
to update the database
with the relevant fix
so if you ran your migration where the
word furniture was spelt incorrectly
within the on model creating method of
your shop online db context class
please follow along with these steps to
fix the issue within your database
please note that the appropriate
spelling fixes regarding all instances
of the word furniture have been uploaded
to the relevant github repository of
course the link to the relevant
repository is included below in the
description
so let's open the shop online db context
class
that can be found in the data folder
within the shoponline.api
project
let's go to the on model creating method
so let's press ctrl f so that we can
perform a find and replace on the
incorrectly spelt word furniture
okay clearly i can't even make the
excuse that this was a typo
look at how consistent i've been in
spelling the word furniture wrong
right let's replace the incorrect
spelling of the word furniture with the
correct spelling of the word furniture
so eight occurrences
and here are some instances where our
find and replace did not fix the
spelling because our search was matching
the whole word
so let's amend the relevant image file
name references for these particular
instances
of course make sure that furniture is
spelled correctly for the relevant
furniture folder and the relevant image
files on your local machines
i did correct the spelling issue before
i uploaded the image files to github so
your file system should contain the
correct spelling from when you
downloaded the relevant files from
github
we can now invoke the package manager
console window from within visual studio
and create a migration to fix our issue
so let's create a new migration by
typing in the add dash migration command
and you can see that the appropriate
code to fix the relevant data in our
database is generated for us in a new
migration class
if we are happy with the relevant
migration code we can run the update
database command to fix the relevant
data in our databases
so let's do that
great
so we are now ready to run our code
in order to run both the web api
component and the blazer component
simultaneously through visual studio we
can configure the shoponline.api project
and the shoponline web project to start
up at the same time like this
but we want the shoponline.api project
to start a little bit earlier
before we run our code let's delete the
index.razer file from within our pages
directory this razer component is also
configured with the same route as we
have configured for our products razer
component and we are not going to use
the index raiser component
that was generated by default in our
application
so now when we first run this code we
are actually going to get an exception
i'll explain why in a bit and then we'll
take steps to resolve the issue
let's press the play button to run the
code
you can see here that we have an
exception coming from our blazer
component
if we press f12 while our chrome
browsers are active
we can examine the relevant error
message here
the exception is caused as a result of
cause
or cross-origin resource sharing
cross-origin resource sharing cause
is a http header-based mechanism that
allows a server to indicate any origins
domain scheme or port
other than its own from which a browser
should permit loading resources
basically this error occurs because our
blazer component has a different base
url to our web api component
as a result of this a security barrier
prevents us from being able to access
the relevant resources returned from our
web api component
let's copy the base url for our blazer
component to our clipboards you'll see
why we are doing this in a bit
we are able to configure a policy within
our web api project
to explicitly allow
for our blazer components to access
relevant resources
so to do this let's open the program.cs
file within our shoponline.api project
and include the relevant course policy
code like this
so where you see the urls in this block
of code
please paste the base url for your
blazer component for the relevant url
arguments
note that we can configure both the http
version of our url and the https version
of our url in this course policy code
and please ensure that you don't include
a forward slash character at the end of
these url arguments
great
let's run the code again
excellent we now have our product data
appropriately displayed to us
when we first load our application
so all is working fine
but if we look at our product dot raiser
file
we can see that we have written quite a
lot of code here
we can make this code that outputs a row
of products reusable by abstracting this
code into its own component
its own razor component
by abstracting this code into its own
razor component we are not only allowing
for the relevant code to be reusable by
other razer parent components
we are also creating cleaner code
so to do this we can create a child
razor component to house the code that
outputs the relevant product data
so let's create a razor component named
displayproducts.razer
let's create a c-sharp class named
display product base which will of
course be the base class for our
displayproducts.razer
component
let's make our display products base
class inherit from the component base
class
we want a parent razor component to be
able to pass an i innumerable collection
of objects of type product dto to our
display products razer child component
we can achieve this by creating a
parameter property within our display
products base class like this
it is important to note that a parameter
property
is decorated with the parameter
attribute
let's go to the display products.razer
file
and implement code to inherit from our
display products base class
then we can go to our products.razer
file
and cut the relevant code and paste it
into our display products.razer file
like this
then we can modify the code
appropriately
so that the code within the display
products.razer file is traversing the i
enumerable collection passed
to the display products child razor
components products parameter
a child component cannot be accessed
directly through a browser and therefore
does not contain a root declaration
a child razor component must be invoked
from within a parent razor component
so let's go to the product's parent
razor component
and call the child
display products child component through
this declarative code
notice how we are able to pass the
relevant collection of objects of type
product dto to the products parameter
that we defined within the display
products child component
and the code for calling the child razor
component from the parent razor
component is very much like typical html
code
by abstracting the code for displaying a
list of products to the user into a
child razor component we have created
cleaner code facilitated easier code
maintenance and the display products
child razor component can be reused from
within other parent components
this will be demonstrated in a later
tutorial
let's run the code
great
so let's say that a requirement arises
where we need to display each product
item under its appropriate product
category
so to answer this requirement
we can create an appropriate link query
to group our objects of type product dto
by product category
like this
we can also include a category heading
for each group of products
and of course each row containing the
grouped products must reside within the
loop like this
let's also include a dividing line
between each product group
let's run the code
great
we can clean up this code even further
by abstracting the relevant link code
within the appropriate base class like
this
great
and let's say that we only wish to
display four items for each product
category we can achieve this by using
links take extension method like this
excellent
the last thing i'd like to do is add
basic animation effects to each of the
bootstrap cards we are using to
represent our products
so to add a css class that only applies
to a particular razor component we can
add a style sheet with a name that
adheres to a specific naming convention
so let's add a css style sheet to the
pages directory
and let's name the stylesheet
displayproduct.razer.css
this naming convention ensures that the
styles contained
within this file will only apply to the
displayproducts.razer component
which is the component that outputs the
bootstrap cards that represent our
products
this tutorial is not about css so i've
pre-prepared the relevant css code
so i'm just going to paste the relevant
code into the display products
dot
file here
this code is of course accessible from
within the relevant github repository
let's run the code
and you can see that when we hover our
mouse pointers over a card the relevant
image scales and a box shadow appears
these basic animation effects have been
included to enhance the user's ux
excellent
so this is the fourth part in a series
of videos dedicated to building a
shopping cart application on.net 6 using
blazer web assembly and web api
we have now created our first workflow
which involves retrieving product data
from the database and displaying the
data to the user in an aesthetically
pleasing style
we have built our database using entity
framework core
we have implemented code using the
repository design pattern
within a web api component in order to
return products data from our database
to a calling client
in the last part of this series part
three
we implemented code for our blazer
webassembly component to call an
appropriate action method within our web
api component
using a http get request in order to
retrieve product data from the server
and display the data to the user in an
aesthetically pleasing style
we want to create functionality to
retrieve data
for a specific product from the server
and display the details of that product
to the user
so when the user clicks on a particular
product only the details for that
specific product are displayed to the
user
the user can then decide whether or not
to add the product to the user's
shopping cart
a button will be provided within the
razer component responsible for
displaying the relevant products details
whereby a user can click this button and
add the relevant product to the user's
shopping cart we'll implement the code
for the add to cart button in the next
tutorial
so let's go to the web api component
let's open the product repository class
and go to the get item method
you can see that currently we have a
default implementation for this method
which was created when we generated the
code stubs
through visual studio of the i product
repository interface that we are
implementing in the product repository
class
so as the name implies the get item
method returns data regarding a single
item
so we can use the find async method to
retrieve the data pertaining to the
product that matches the id value passed
into the get item method through code
like this
the next step is to expose the
functionality to a calling client by
implementing code that gets executed in
reaction to an appropriate http get
request
so we want the get item functionality to
execute when a calling client makes an
appropriate http get request for product
data that can be identified in the
system with the id value passed to our
web api component from the calling
client
we can implement code that creates an
appropriate http response
through creating an action method within
our product controller controller class
so let's create a method within the
product controller class to return data
for a particular product
to speed things up let's duplicate the
get items action method that we created
in the second part of this series
and change the code appropriately so as
to implement the functionality for the
get item action method
we only want to return data for one
object of type product dto rather than
an i enumerable collection of objects of
type product dto to the calling client
so let's change the return type
appropriately
let's include a parameter named id which
is of type integer
this id parameter denotes the id value
of the product data for which the client
wishes to have returned from our web api
component within the http get attribute
let's include the appropriate root
template information
our get item action method contains a
parameter of type integer named id
so for the get item action method it is
appropriate to pass in an argument of
type string
to its corresponding
http get attribute that denotes the
appropriate root template for this
action method
so let's use the product repository
object passed into our controller class
via dependency injection to call the
getitem method
that we have just implemented within the
product repository class
so if the returned value is null this
means that the resource does not exist
so let's pass a response to the calling
client
that includes a bad request status code
we can do this in code by returning the
result returned from the bad request
method like this so let's say we also
want to include the name of the category
under which the relevant product
falls
in the returned object
as we know we only have the id of the
category under which the returned
product falls within the product entity
we don't have the facility to store any
other information pertaining to the
products category within the product
entity
so we need to write code to get the
category information from the product
category entity
we can then include the product
information and the category information
in an object of type product dto and
return the relevant object of type
product dto to the calling client
so let's implement code for the get
category method within the product
repository class to retrieve data
for our specific category based on the
category id passed into this method
let's then write code within our get
item action method to appropriately call
the get category method on the object of
type
i product repository like this
the next step is to write the code that
merges the data pertaining to a specific
product
with the data pertaining to the relevant
products category
into one object of type product dto in
order to write the code for this in a
clean way
we can create a convert to dto extension
method overload within our dto
conversions class so the convert to dto
extension method currently within our
dto conversions class converts a
collection of products and a collection
of product categories
appropriately into a collection of
objects of type product eto and returns
the collection of objects of type
product dto to the calling code
we want our new convert to dto extension
method overload to convert one object of
type product and related object of type
product category into one object of type
product dto and return the subject of
type product dto to the calling code
this is basically so that we can include
the relevant product data and the
category name within one object
our product dto type facilitates this
so we can write code to perform the
relevant conversion like this
we can now go to our get item action
method and call the convert to dto
extension method
which is now available on this object of
type product to return the appropriate
object of type product dto to our action
method
we can then write code to return a http
status code of 200 okay
along with the relevant object of type
product dto to the calling client by
appropriately returning the result of
the ok method and passing in the
appropriate object of type product dto
to the ok method
if an exception occurs for some reason
during the execution of the get item
action method
we have code here that will return a
http status code of 500 denoting an
internal server error
to the calling client along with an
appropriate error message
great
so let's write code within the blazer
component
to make an appropriate http call to the
server side code that we have just
implemented
so let's open our i product service
interface
let's include a method definition for a
method
where we will implement the code to call
the get item action method on the server
we want this getitem method to run
asynchronously so we are returning a
task object
the getitem method is returning a value
so we must pass the return type as a
type argument
to the generic task type here
this method contains a parameter of type
integer and is named id
this id parameter denotes the id value
that is used to identify a specific
product
so let's implement the get item method
in the product service class
let's generate a try catch block
in the previous part of this series part
3 we implemented code for the get items
method that uses the http client objects
get from json async method to call the
relevant server side action method
this method calls the relevant action
method but also handles translating the
returned json data into the appropriate
objects type
i'm going to use the get async method to
call the relevant action method in our
get item method this method doesn't
convert the returned json data to the
appropriate object type we need to write
code for this separately we'll do that
in a bit the get async method returns a
http response object
so we can use the returned object to
first ascertain
as to whether our http request to the
server was successful
so this code checks that the relevant
status code falls within the success
range
so if the call is successful we want
code
to execute that checks if our http
request has returned a response with
content
if there is no content returned from the
server we want code executed that
returns
the default value associated with the
product dto type like this
so the c sharp default value for a user
defines type which is a reference type
will be null
so this is just the way i'm choosing to
handle the scenario where the call to
the server is successful but for some
reason no data is returned from the
server
so when the call is successful and
content is returned from the server we
want code to execute that translates the
json data returned from the server into
an object of the appropriate type
else if the call to the server is not
successful we want code to execute that
handles the exception
so here we are just going to throw the
exception at this point
and we can pass the message sent back
from the server as an argument to the
exception object like this
within the catch block
we could implement codes to log the
exception or handle the exception
in an appropriate manner that we choose
let's implement appropriate code within
the get items method to also include
exception handling functionality
so let's create a razor component within
the pages folder
let's name this component
productdetails.razer
so this is the component where we'll
implement the code to display details
regarding a specific product
let's create the base class for our
product details component and let's name
this component product details base
let's implement the code for our product
details base class
we want the id parameter that denotes
the identifier for a specific product to
be passed into the component so let's
create a parameter named id that is of
type integer
we need to decorate this property with
the parameter attribute
we also need to ensure
that our base class inherits from the
component base class
so we want an object of type i product
service to be injected into our product
details component
so we can do this by including a
property within our base class of type i
product service
and decorate the relevant property with
the inject attribute
let's include a property of type product
dto within our base class
and let's name this property product
let's include a string property to store
an exception message
so we want code to execute when our
blazer component is first invoked
so we can ensure that this happens by
writing the relevant code within a
method that overrides the uninitialized
async method
to generate the appropriate
uninitialized async method let's type in
override followed by pressing the space
bar and then let's select the
appropriate method from the list
presented to us
let's generate a try catch block
within the try catch block let's
appropriately call the get item method
on the injected object of type i product
service the returned value is assigned
to our product property
which we can then access from our
product details.razer file
if an exception occurs we want the
exception message to be assigned to the
error message property
let's implement code to output details
regarding the relevant product
so let's ensure that we include the
appropriate root template at the top of
the file
we can use the page directive for this
purpose and notice how we are including
the id parameter here
this is because an appropriate id
parameter must be passed to this razor
component when this razor component is
invoked
let's write the code logic
so while the product property is null
and the error message property is null
we want a loading indicator to be
displayed to the user
else if an error occurs in which case
the error message property will not be
null we want the error message to be
displayed
please note that for the sake of this
example we are writing functionality to
display the error message returned from
the server to the screen
in a complete application it would be
more appropriate to output a
user-friendly non-technical error
message to the user and log the actual
error message returned from the server
else we want to output the details of
the relevant product in an aesthetically
pleasing style to the user
and of course bootstrap 5 classes are
being used here to output the data in an
aesthetically pleasing style
great
then let's go to the display
products.razer file and include the
appropriate value for the href attribute
within the anchor tag that wraps the
cards that represent the products sold
in our online store
so we want this link to invoke the
product details razer component
we need to include the appropriate id
value denoting the identifier for a
specific product within our href
attribute value here
let's run the code
great
let's abstract the code that outputs an
exception to the user in its own razor
component
so that we can reuse this component from
within multiple parent razor components
this is also a cleaner way of
implementing the code that displays an
error message to the user
let's write code to force an exception
to occur
so we know that a product with an id of
1000 does not exist in the system
so in this case the server will send
back a response code indicating that a
bad request has been made
let's run the code
great
lastly it would be better in terms of a
user's ux
if an appropriate animated loading
indicator was displayed to the user
while the user is waiting for data to be
displayed
so if we navigate to this site here
we can copy the relevant html and css
code for an animated loading indicator
of our choice
these loading indicators here can be
used within our application free of
charge
so let's select this one
let's copy the html and the css code for
the loading indicator of our choice and
integrate the code within our
application
the cleanest way to integrate this code
into our applications
in my opinion is to abstract the loading
indicator code within a razor component
as discussed in the previous part of
this series part 3 we are able to create
a css file
that only applies
to its corresponding razer component
by naming the relevant css file in a way
that adheres to a specific naming
convention
so if the name of the razer component is
display spinner we can create a css file
that will only apply to this razor
component by naming the relevant css
file display
spinner.razer.css so we can now reuse
the spinner functionality
for multiple parent components
i look forward to presenting the next
video in this series where we'll create
the functionality for adding products to
a shopping cart
this is the fifth part in a video series
dedicated to building a shopping cart
application using
blazerwebassemblyon.net 6.
so we have completed the implementation
of two workflows
the first workflow involves retrieving
the data pertaining to the products sold
by our online store
and displaying the data in an
aesthetically pleasing style to the user
the second workflow involves displaying
details for a particular product to the
screen
in response to the user clicking on a
card representing the relevant product
in this video we'll create the
functionality whereby the user clicks
the add to cart button
which is available on the screen where
details for a particular product are
displayed
this button click action will result in
the relevant product being added to the
user's shopping cart
after the user has clicked the add to
cart button
the user will subsequently be navigated
to a screen that displays data
pertaining to the products currently
contained within the user's shopping
cart
so let's get started
so let's first implement the
functionality for the server side code
so let's go to our project
that contains the functionality for our
web api component
in the second part of this video series
we implemented the repository design
pattern for functionality to handle
database interactions regarding the
products sold by our online store
so we now want to create the code for
handling the database functionality
pertaining to the shopping cart
so let's create an interface that
contains the method definitions for the
shopping cart repository class that
we'll create once we have created its
interface
so let's create an interface named i
shopping cart repository
let's create a method definition for a
method named add item
as the name suggests
the code that we'll implement for this
method will add a particular product to
the relevant user's shopping cart
let's add a method definition for a
method named update qty
when a user first adds a product to the
user's shopping cart
the quantity of the relevant product
added to the user's shopping cart will
be won by default
the implementation for this method will
involve updating the quantity of a
particular product
that is currently contained within a
user's shopping cart
let's add a method definition for a
method named delete item
as the name suggests the functionality
for this method will involve removing a
particular product from the user's
shopping cart
the get item method will contain
functionality for retrieving data
regarding a particular product that is
currently in the user's shopping cart
the get items method will contain
functionality for retrieving data for
all the products that are currently in a
particular user's shopping cart
so let's create a class named shopping
cart repository
let's write codes to implement the i
shopping cart repository interface that
we have just created
let's position our mouse pointers
appropriately and press control period
in order to bring in the appropriate
namespace ie where the i shopping cart
repository interface resides
let's press control period and generate
the code stubs for the method
definitions that we included within the
i shopping cart repository interface
so in this video
we are going to implement functionality
for three of the methods that we have
defined within the i shopping cart
repository interface namely add item get
items and get item
before we do this let's create a
constructor
let's add a parameter to our constructor
that is of type shop online db context
by including this parameter we are
indicatingto.net that we want an object
of this type injected into our shopping
cart repository class at runtime
we have already registered the shop
online db context type for dependency
injection
the shop online db context type is the
ef core database context object that is
used for handling data manipulation and
data retrieval functionality in relation
to our applications database
so let's implement the functionality for
the add item method
let's first write a link query that
ensures that the product that the user
is attempting to add
to the user's shopping cart exists in
the products table
so if the item returned
from our link query is not null
we want code to execute that adds the
relevant product to the cart items
database table
this denotes that the product has been
added to the user's shopping cart
so let's implement the code to add the
item to the cart items database table
once we have called the add async method
we must also remember to call the save
changes async method
then we can write code
to return the entity
that has been successfully added to the
cart items database table like this
if an item is not successfully added to
the database we want code to execute
that will return null to the calling
code
so in order to avoid a product being
added twice to our user's shopping cart
let's implement code that checks to see
if the relevant product already exists
within the user's shopping cart
let's implement the code for this in a
private method
that returns a boolean value
then we can use the private method we
have just created like this to perform
the relevant check
so we have ensured that only one
instance of a particular product can be
added to the user's shopping cart
please note that the user will be able
to purchase more than one instance of a
particular product by appropriately
modifying the qty or quantity field
we'll implement this at a later stage
let's implement the code for the get
items method
let's write code that returns the
results of a link query pertaining to
the products currently stored within the
user's shopping cart
then let's write code for the get item
method
let's write code that returns the
results of a link query which is data
pertaining to a particular product
currently stored
within the relevant user's shopping cart
let's add a controller class to the
controllers folder
let's name this controller class
shopping cart controller
firstly let's create a constructor that
contains two parameters one of type i
shopping cart repository and the other
of type i product
repository let's create two read-only
fields
to reference the objects that will be
injected into our controller class at
runtime
let's of course not forget to register
the i shopping cart repository type for
dependency injection
so let's implement the code for the get
items action method
let's use our shopping cart repository
object to return the items currently
stored within the relevant user's
shopping cart
if no items are contained within the
shopping cart we want code to execute
that returns a http response of no
content to the calling client
this is denoted by a http code status of
204
so this means the client http request
was successful but no items related to
the client's request are present in the
system therefore no content can be
returned to the calling client
so we are returning a collection of type
can't item dto to the client from the
action method
we have just written code that retrieves
a collection of objects of type cart
item
we want to return a collection of
objects of type can't item dto to the
calling client the cart item dto type
contains additional data regarding the
relevant product
we don't have the additional data at
this point so let's use the product
repository object
to retrieve a collection of objects of
type product
we can then write code to join our
collection of card item objects with the
collection of objects of type product
using a link query and return an
appropriate collection of objects of
type can't item dto
to the calling client
so let's keep this code clean and
implement a linq query
in an extension method to return the
relevant collection of objects of type
cart item dto to the get items action
method
before we do this let's write code to
throw an exception if no products exist
within the system because if there are
no products in the system and the user
is attempting to add a product to the
user's shopping cart well this won't
make any sense
so this means an exception has occurred
let's write code in a catch block that
returns a http status code of 500 to the
calling code
so if for some reason an exception
occurs during the execution of the get
items action method we want an internal
server error 500 http response to be
returned to the client
so let's go to the dto conversions class
and implement another extension method
overload named convert to dto
we'll be able to call this extension
method overload on an i enumerable
collection of type cart item to perform
the relevant conversion functionality
let's go to our get items action method
and call the extension method we have
just created
to return the appropriate collection of
objects of type cat item dto
we can then write code to return this
collection to the calling client with a
http response status code of 200 okay
let's implement the code for the get
item action method
you can see here
that the code is very similar to the get
items action method but we of course
are only returning one item of type cart
item dto to the calling client instead
of a collection of objects of type cart
item dto
so let's write code
for converting an object of type card
item to an object of type cart item dto
to do this let's go to the dto
conversion class and implement the code
for the appropriate extension method
overload
we can then call the relevant convert to
dto extension method on the relevant
object of type cart item to perform the
appropriate conversion functionality
let's write the functionality for
handling a post request
from the client whereby a user is
attempting to add
a product to the user's shopping cart
so let's write code to call the add item
method on the shopping cart repository
object that will be injected into our
controller class at runtime
we want to return the newly added item
of type cart item dto to the calling
client
so we can call the same conversion code
that we implemented for the get item
method for this purpose
it is important to note
that it is standard practice for a post
action method to return the location of
the resource where the newly added item
can be found
this location will be returned in the
header of the http response returned
from this method
we can use the create at action method
to ensure that we are adhering to this
standard practice
so the relevant resource can be found at
the uri universal resource identifier
pertaining to the get item action method
and we are including the id
of the newly added resource here
and for the final argument we are
including the newly added object which
we have now converted to type cart item
dto
if you'd like to read more about the
create at action method i've included an
appropriate link below in the
description
and we of course need to decorate this
action method with the http post
attribute
let's run the shoponline.api project
through visual studio
and you can see
the new action methods
and relevant dtos are present on the
swagger ui web page
great
let's implement the relevant code for
our blazer component so let's go to the
shoponline.web project
let's create a new service class where
we'll implement code that interacts
with the action methods
that we have created within our shopping
cart controller class in our web api
project
firstly let's create the appropriate
interface in the contracts folder for
the relevant service class
let's name this interface i shopping
cart service
let's create a method definition for the
get items method
and the add items method
let's create a class named shopping cart
service
let's generate the code stubs for the
methods defined within the i shopping
cart service interface
let's create a constructor for the
shopping cart service class
let's include a parameter of type http
client as a parameter within our
constructor
this parameter indicates to.net that we
want an object of type http client
injected into this class at runtime
let's implement the code for the add
item method
so basically this code calls the post
action method that we implemented in the
shopping cart controller class
if the response http status code
is within the success range let's check
to see if any content was returned if no
content was returned let's return the
default c-sharp value for the cart item
dto type to the calling code
which will be null
if content was returned
from the server
let's return the object representing the
newly created shopping cart item to the
calling code this will of course be an
object of type can't item dto
let's include the relevant exception
handling code
let's implement code for the get items
method
so i'm deliberately including an
incorrect uri universal resource
identifier
reference here
so that this will force an exception
when we run the code we'll fix this
a little bit later after we have run the
code that tests how an application
handles the relevant exception
this code simply places a http get
request to the get items action method
and if content is returned returns the
relevant content to the relevant razer
component i.e the calling code
let's go to the product details base
class and implement a button click event
handler method for the add to cart
button
let's name this click event handler
method add to cart underscore click
let's make sure that we have registered
the i shopping cart service type for
dependency injection
let's implement code that ensures that
an object of type i shopping cart
service is injected into the product
details base class at runtime
then our code within the add to cart
underscore click event handler method
calls the add item method
on the injected shopping cart service
object to add a product chosen by the
user to the user's shopping cart
let's go to the product details.razer
file and implement the code that calls
the add to cart underscore click event
handler method
so we have started with the
implementation of the shopping cart
functionality we have not implemented
user registration or login functionality
ie membership functionality in this
application
we could implement codes to bring down
user related information from the server
when the user first logs onto the system
the information could include the user's
user id
and the user's cart id
so because we haven't implemented login
functionality let's temporarily hard
code the user's cart id and user id in a
class within the project that contains
our blazer functionality so that we can
progress with the implementation of the
shopping cart functionality
so in the first video in this series we
seeded the data with data for two users
so let's say that we are going to run
the code from the perspective of the
user that has a user id of one and a
cart id of one
so we can now pass in the hard-coded
cart id value here
along with the relevant product id
and a quantity of one when a user adds a
product to the user's shopping cart by
default one instance of that product is
added to the user's shopping cart
let's strategically add some breakpoints
in the blazer project and the web api
project
and run the code
and let's invoke the functionality for
the workflow that we have just
implemented incurred by clicking a
product that we wish to add to the
shopping cart
and then let's click the add to cart
button
great
if we look at the cart items database
table
we can see an item has been
appropriately inserted into the relevant
table
let's test this again
great
let's create a razor component that will
be responsible for rendering a
collection of products data pertaining
to products that have been added to the
user's shopping cart to the screen
so let's add a razor component named
shoppingcart.razer
let's add a base class for the shopping
cart razor component let's name this
class shopping cart base
let's implement code for the shopping
cart base class
so our shopping cart base class must
inherit from the component base class
because we want this class to be the
base class for the shopping cart raiser
component
let's write code for injecting an object
of type i shopping cart service into our
class at runtime
let's include a property for referencing
a collection of objects of type cart
item dto
this property will be used within the
shoppingcart.razer file
for code that displays the relevant data
to the screen
let's create the code to override the
uninitialized async method where we'll
implement code for assigning the
relevant collection of items returned
from the server to the shopping cart
items property when the razer component
is first rendered
great
let's implement the code for the
shoppingcart.razer file
let's include the page directive at the
top to declare the root template for our
shopping cart razor component
let's use the inherits directive to
ensure that we are using the shopping
cart base class as the razer components
base class
so while the shopping cart items
property is null
and the error message property is null
we want a spinner loading indicator to
be displayed to the user
if the error message property is not
null we want the relevant error message
to be displayed to the user
else
we want code to run that displays in an
aesthetically pleasing style the data
representing a collection of products
that have been added to the user's
shopping cart
we are using bootstrap 5 classes for
styling the html elements
in our razer file
now that we have written the code for
displaying a collection of products data
for products added to the user's
shopping cart let's write code that
navigates the user
to this screen
after the user clicks the add to cart
button
so let's go to the add to cart
underscore click event handler method
within the product details base class
and implement the relevant code
so we can use an object of type
navigation manager to navigate the user
to the relevant screen
so let's write code to ensure
that an object of type navigation
manager is injected into our razer
component at runtime
let's then invoke the navigate to method
on the navigation manager object to
navigate the user to the shopping cart
screen
let's run the code
and an error message is displayed to us
this is because we are forcing a 404 not
found error to occur
at the moment
we have included an incorrect path to
the end point that returns the
collection of card item dto objects
within the get items method of the
shopping cart service class
we need to appropriately include a
reference to the shopping cart
controller name within this uri
reference so let's correct this uri
universal resource identifier
by appropriately including the relevant
controller name here
great
this is the sixth part in a video series
dedicated to building a shopping cart
application
using
blazerwebassemblyon.net 6.
so we have created three workflows let's
recap the first workflow involves
retrieving products data from the
database and displaying the products
data to the user in an aesthetically
pleasing style
the second workflow involves retrieving
details for an individual product and
displaying the relevant details in an
aesthetically pleasing style to the user
the third workflow involves the user
adding a product to the user's shopping
cart and the user being navigated to a
screen that displays a list of products
contained within the user's shopping
cart
in this video we'll create the workflow
that involves a user removing a product
from the user's shopping cart
let's get started
let's start by implementing the server
side code
let's go to our shoponline.api project
and open the shopping cart repository.cs
file
let's implement the code logic for the
delete item method
so we can use the id value that will be
passed into this method to find the
entity that we wish to delete from the
cart items database table
we are using the find async method to
find the relevant entity using the
primary key field
which is the id field if we find the
relevant entity if the item returned
from the find async method is not null
we can use the remove method to remove
the relevant entity from the cart items
database table
then we mustn't forget to call the save
changes async method to commit the
relevant change to our database
in order to make this delete
functionality available to calling
client code
let's create an appropriate endpoint
within our web api component
so let's go to the shopping cart
controller class
and create an appropriate action method
that will call the relevant delete item
method that we have just implemented
in the shopping cart repository class
let's decorate our delete item action
method with an attribute that declares
that this action method corresponds to
the http delete verb
so far in the development of our
application we have created endpoints
that correspond to both the get and post
http verbs
we are about to implement the logic for
an endpoint that corresponds to the
delete http verb
let's declare the relevant root template
information for our action method by
passing an appropriate string argument
to the http delete attribute
this information includes a definition
for the id that needs to be part of the
uri universal resource identifier
pertaining to the entity that a client
wishes to delete
so we are essentially enabling a calling
client to delete a specific resource
from the system
let's create a try catch block a simple
way to create the relevant code for this
is to type try followed by pressing the
tab key twice
let's call the delete item method on the
shopping cart repository object
that will be injected into the
constructor of this controller class at
runtime
if the entity that the client wishes to
delete
cannot be found
we want code to execute that returns a
http response code of not found 404
to the client
the information that we want transferred
across the network for the relevant
entity that the client wishes to delete
is of type can't item dto
and not the type cart item that is
returned from the delete item method
called on the shopping cart repository
object
in the previous part of this video
series part 5 we implemented an
extension method overload named convert
to dto within the dto conversions class
this extension method can be called on
any object of type cart item
before we appropriately call the convert
to dto extension method
we must retrieve the relevant product
entity from the database so let's write
the code to achieve this
then let's call the convert to dto
method on the object of type cart item
returned from the shopping cart
repository classes delete item method to
convert the relevant object of type cart
item to an object of type cart item dto
then let's write code to return a http
response code of ok200
to the client along with the relevant
object of type cart item dto
let's complete this method by writing
code that executes
if for some reason an exception is
thrown during the execution of the code
logic within the delete item action
method
let's go to our blazer component so
let's go to
the shoponline.web project
let's add an appropriate new method
definition to the i shopping cart
service interface named delete item
let's open the shopping cart service
class and implement the code logic for
the delete item method
if the http response code returned from
the server
falls within the success range
we want code to execute that returns an
object of type can't item dto to the
calling code
if the call to the server is not
successful we want null to be returned
to the calling code
let's open the shopping cart base class
within the pages folder
let's implement code for a method that
handles a button click event
so this method will be called when a
user clicks a delete button
that we'll create in a bit in the
shoppingcart.razer file
let's appropriately call the delete item
method on the shopping cart service
object
that will be injected into our razor
component at runtime
so this code will call the appropriate
action method on the server side
that will delete the relevant entity
cart item from our database
so we want the results of this deletion
operation to be reflected on the user
interface
which means we need the shopping cart
razor component to re-render once the
deletion operation has completed
successfully
we could call the appropriate get items
method and retrieve all the relevant
shopping cart items that are currently
saved to our database for the relevant
user
and assign the results to the shopping
cart items property
and the result of the deletion operation
would then appropriately be reflected on
the ui
however
we can implement code for a solution
that will be more performant for this
purpose
than the solution that i've just
expressed i.e that involves an
additional call to the server-side code
we can reflect the results of a deletion
operation on the ui
by simply deleting the relevant cart
item object from the client side
collection of card items
referenced by our shopping cart items
property
by deleting the relevant item from the
client side collection we are avoiding a
trip as it were to the server side
this could result in a significant
performance benefit
so let's create a private method
responsible for removing the relevant
item from the client side shopping cart
items collection
we first need a variable that references
the object within the shopping cart
items collection that we wish to delete
so let's create another private method
that contains code for returning a
specific object within the shopping cart
items collection
let's then call our new private method
to return the object that we wish to
delete from the shopping cart items
collection to our remove card item
method
we can then implement code to delete the
relevant item from the relevant
client-side shopping cart items
collection
but there is a problem with this at the
moment
our client site collection stored within
the shopping cart items property is
currently of type i enumerable
the i enumerable type is fine for when
we need to traverse through the items in
the relevant collection
but we don't currently have an easy way
available to us to remove an item from
the relevant client-side collection
one solution to this problem is that we
can change the type of our client side
collection to type list
we must also appropriately change the
return type of the delete item method
definition in the i shopping cart
service interface and of course we must
also appropriately change the return
type
for the implementation of this method
in the shopping cart service class
let's go back to the shopping cart base
class
and use the remove method
on the shopping cart items collection
which is now of type list to remove the
relevant item from the relevant client
side collection
let's appropriately call our remove cart
item method
from within the delete cart item
underscore click event handler method
let's create the delete button within
the shoppingcart.razer file
let's use blazers at on click syntax to
ensure that our delete can't item
underscore click
functionality is triggered when the user
clicks our new button
let's run the code and test our method
great
okay so i don't like this empty screen
displayed to the user here
when the user no longer has any cart
items saved to the user's shopping cart
so let's ensure that status information
is outputted to the user
for the case where the user's shopping
cart is empty
so we can do this by using the count
method
so if the count method returns a value
greater than zero we can output the data
contained within the shopping cart items
property as well as the relevant
shopping cart summary information
else let's output a basic message to the
user informing the user that the user's
shopping cart is empty
let's run the code
great
so i think rather than display the text
remove on the relevant button
i think the standard trash icon would
look better
let's use font awesome for this purpose
i'm going to use an appropriate cdn
cloud delivery network link to reference
the relevant font awesome css file
so if we go to this website we can copy
the relevant link here
and we can then paste it into our
index.html file in order to include font
awesome icons within our application
we are now able to reference the font
awesome trash icon like this to display
the trash icon on our delete button
excellent
i hope you've enjoyed this video i look
forward to presenting the next video in
this series
where we'll continue to develop our
shopping cart application we are going
to implement the update quantity
functionality in the next video
this is the seventh part of a video
series dedicated to building a shopping
cart application
using
blazerwebassemblyon.net 6.
so in the previous part of this series
we created functionality whereby a user
can delete an item from the user's
shopping cart
in this video we are going to create the
functionality whereby a user is able to
update the quantity
of a particular product that has been
placed within the user's shopping cart
a notable feature that we'll add
is the showing and hiding of the update
qty button so we only want the update
qty button to appear when the user
changes the appropriate value in the
field denoting the quantity of a
particular item in the user's shopping
cart
when the relevant field is changed the
relevant update qty button appears once
the user has clicked the update qty
button to update the quantity of a
particular item in the user's shopping
cart we want the update qty button to
disappear
to achieve the appropriate showing and
hiding of the update qty button we are
going to invoke a javascript method
this brings us to an important question
how do we integrate javascript into our
blazer webassembly component
in this video we are going to look at
how we can use blaze's javascript
interoperability feature to interact
with javascript code from within our
blazer webassembly component
we'll implement this functionality
toward the end of the video so please
stick around to the end to learn about
javascript interoperability with blazer
to start with let's create the
server-side code for the update qty
functionality so let's get started let's
go to the shoponline.api project
let's open the shopping cart repository
class
let's implement the code logic for the
update qty method
first thing to do is reference the item
that we wish to update
so if we are able to find the relevant
item within our database and therefore
the item variable will not be null
we can then update the qty field with
the value passed in from the client
and to commit the change to the database
we must of course call the save changes
async method
let's write code to return null to the
calling client for when the item is not
found within the database
let's expose the update quantity
functionality to our calling client
through an action method
let's open the shopping cart controller
class
let's create an action method named
update qty
let's appropriately call the update qty
method on the shopping cart repository
object to update the relevant resource
with the qty value passed into our
action method by the client
let's use our convert to dto method to
appropriately convert the cart item
object into an object of type cart item
dto we can then write code to return the
relevant object of type cart item dto to
the calling client
along with the http code status of 200
ok
let's include the appropriate exception
handling code
so we have so far created action methods
that correspond to the http get verb the
http post verb and the http delete verb
the other two most common http verbs
are the http put verb and the http patch
verb the http put verb and the http
patch verb
are both associated with the performance
of resource updates
the difference between these two http
verbs is that the http put verb is
associated with action methods that
modify a resource where the client sends
data that updates the entire resource
the http patch verb however is
associated with action methods that
partially update the respective resource
so we want our update qty method
to update only the qty field for a cart
item resource
so this means it is appropriate to
associate our update qty action method
with the http patch verb
we can write declarative code to
indicate that this action method is
associated with a http patch verb to do
this we can appropriately decorate the
update qty action method with the http
patch attribute like this
note that we are passing in data to the
http patch attribute that provides
necessary route template information
this indicates that the uri for the
relevant endpoint must appropriately
contain the id of the resource that the
client wishes to modify
right let's write the appropriate code
for the blazer component
so let's go to the shoponline.web
project
let's open the i shopping cart service
class
let's open the shopping cart service
class to implement the code logic for
the update qty method
let's first serialize the dto that we
wish to pass to the server into json
format
let's create an object of type string
content so that we can appropriately
pass the relevant data in the
appropriate format to the server
let's call the patch async method on our
http client object and pass in the
appropriate uri
as well as the relevant data
to the patch async method
if the http response status code falls
within the success range let's include
code that returns the appropriate data
returned from the server to the calling
code
let's go to the shopping cart base class
let's create a method that will handle
the update qty button click event so the
calling code will pass in the id of the
shopping cart item that the user wishes
to update as well as the relevant
quantity value
if the quantity value is greater than
zero meaning that the quantity or qty
field value is valid
we can appropriately call the update qty
method on the shopping cart service
object
to call the relevant server side code in
order to update the database
appropriately
else if the calling code passes in an
invalid quantity let's set the quantity
field
for the relevant cart item to one
let's go to the shopping cart dot raise
a file
let's add an input field that will allow
a user to modify the quantity of a
particular item in the user's shopping
cart
note that we are using blazers at bind
syntax to bind each quantity input field
to the corresponding property of the
appropriate object of type cart item dto
stored within the shopping cart items
collection
this means for example that if the qty
property for a cart item dto object
stored within the shopping cart items
collection is modified that this
modification will immediately be
reflected on the ui in the appropriate
quantity input field
let's create the update qty button
that a user can click in order to update
the quantity of a particular item
let's use blazes at onclick syntax to
call the appropriate event handler
method that we have created within the
shopping cart base class
let's stand by our convention to use the
underscore click suffix
for these type of event handler methods
so let's change the name of the relevant
method
from update qty cart item to update qty
cart item underscore click
then we can write code to pass in the
appropriate values to our update qty
cart item underscore click method
let's test the code
great
so we haven't yet written code so that
the total quantity and total price is
reflected within the cart item summary
information displayed to the user on the
right-hand side of the user's screen
let's implement the code for this
so firstly let's include two properties
within our shopping cart base class
let's include a property to store the
total price of the items within the
user's shopping cart
and the total quantity of the items
stored within the user's shopping cart
let's create a private method named set
total price
which is responsible for calculating the
total price of all the items stored
within the user's shopping cart and
assigning the result of this calculation
to the relevant property
let's create a private method named set
total quantity which is responsible for
calculating the total quantity of items
stored within the user's shopping cart
and assigning the result of this
calculation to the relevant property
let's create a private method named
calculate cart item summary totals let's
call the set total price method as well
as the set total quantity method from
within the calculate cart summary totals
method
we want the total price of all the items
stored within the user's shopping cart
as well as the total quantity of items
stored within the user's shopping cart
to be reflected on the ui whenever a
user action results in the state of the
shopping cart changing
so let's appropriately call our
calculate card summary totals method
from within the update qty cart item
underscore click event handler method
the delete cart item underscore click
event handler method
and the on initialized async method that
is called when the razer component is
rendered
let's go to the shoppingcart.racer file
and implement the code that will result
in the appropriate summary totals being
reflected appropriately on the ui
before we run the code we must also
include a method in the shopping cart
base class
that updates the total price property on
the relevant object of type cart item
dto when the relevant quantity property
is updated for a particular cart item by
the user
so basically if for example a cart item
has a price of 50 dollars and the user
updates its quantity property
from one to two
we need to change the cart items total
price
from fifty dollars to a hundred dollars
to calculate the total price
is simply a mathematical operation
of price multiplied by quantity
so let's create a method named update
item total price
let's call our get card item private
method
to reference the relevant cart item
then we can update its total price
property with the result of the
calculation that we have just discussed
we want our update item total price
method invoked
every time the quantity for an item
within the user's shopping cart changes
so let's implement the code for this
appropriately
great
let's run the code
excellent
so let's look at javascript
interoperability in a blazer webassembly
component
let's implement the code so that our
update qty button is only shown
to the user when the state of the
relevant input field changes
so let's first create a css file for our
shopping cart razor component
so let's create a css file named
shoppingcart.razer.css
as discussed when we create a css file
that only applies to a specific razor
component we must adhere to a specific
naming convention
let's create a css class named update
dash
qty that contains the code display colon
none
so we can apply this class to the update
qty button like this to ensure
that when the relevant razer component
first loads that the update qty button
is not displayed to the user
so the next step is to create a
javascript method that is invoked when
the quantity input field is changed by
the user
this javascript method will be
responsible for appropriately showing
and hiding the relevant update qty
button
let's create a folder within the www
root folder of our project named js
let's add a javascript file named
shoppingcartfunctions.js to the js
folder
let's create a javascript function named
make update qty button visible
this function accepts two arguments
one denotes the id of the relevant cart
item and the other denotes a boolean
value
so in order to be able to identify the
relevant button within our javascript
code we can apply a data attribute to
the relevant html element
so let's go to our shoppingcart.razer
file and include a data attribute named
data dash item id and set its value to
the id of the relevant cart item
the code for the javascript function is
fairly basic
let's use our data attribute to
reference the appropriate button element
we are using the data dash item id
data attribute to identify a specific
update qty button
if the boolean value is true
we want code to execute within our
javascript function to make the relevant
button visible
if the boolean value is false we want
our function to make the relevant button
invisible
let's appropriately reference our new
javascript file from within the
index.html file
then we need to write code to detect
when a quantity input field or qty input
field is changed by the user
we can use blaze's at on input syntax
for this purpose
one might think that the at on change
syntax
should be used for this purpose but a
method executed in response to the at
once syntax
will only be invoked when the relevant
input field loses focus
we want our method to be invoked
immediately when the relevant input
field's value changes
so let's implement a method within the
shoppingcartbase.cs class that will be
invoked when a quantity input field is
changed
so we want our make update qty button
visible javascript function to be
invoked when a quantity input field is
changed
so how can we call a javascript function
from within a razer component
the answer to this is that we can use
the built-in js runtime type for this
purpose so let's create a property of
type i js runtime
let's decorate this property with the
inject attribute so that an appropriate
object of type ijs runtime will be
injected into our razor component at
runtime
we can then use the object to
appropriately call our make update qty
button visible javascript function like
this
let's go to our shopping cart dot race
of file and appropriately call our
update qty underscore input method
lastly let's write code that calls the
relevant javascript function to make the
relevant update qty button disappear
once the relevant button has been
clicked
let's run the code
excellent
this is the eighth part of a video
series dedicated to building a shopping
cart application using
blazerwebassemblyon.net 6.
so at this point we have achieved quite
a lot
we have created the functionality for
displaying grouped products to the user
we have also created most of the
functionality for the shopping cart
a user can now add a product to the
shopping cart remove a product from the
shopping cart and can update the
quantity of a product that is contained
within the shopping cart
so we now need a way for a user to be
able to navigate to the shopping cart
from anywhere within the application
we also want the user to be able to see
at a glance
how many items are currently contained
within the user's shopping cart
currently the user is only able to
navigate to the shopping cart through
our application by adding a product to
the shopping cart
we want the user to be able to see how
many items have been added to the user's
shopping cart at a glance no matter
where the user is within the application
for example the user may be viewing the
grouped products displayed to the user
when the application is first launched
and wishes to know how many items are
currently contained within the user's
shopping cart
we also want the user to be able to
navigate to the user's shopping cart
through our application from anywhere
within the application simply by
clicking a button
so we want to make this button
accessible to the user from anywhere in
the application
so in this video we'll provide an
appropriate solution for this we'll
provide a button in the header part of
the ui that when clicked will navigate
the user to the user's shopping cart
the quantity of items stored within the
user's shopping cart will be displayed
on the text of the relevant button
so the quantity value displayed on the
relevant button must be kept up to date
so we must facilitate the change of the
relevant quantity value whenever the
number of items within the shopping cart
changes
the code for the button containing the
text representing the number of items in
the user's shopping cart will be
contained within its own razor component
a razor component we'll name cart menu
so this means we need to find a way to
send data to the cart menu razor
component from other relevant razer
components like for example the shopping
cart razor component whereby code must
execute that updates the relevant
quantity value
when a change to the number of items
stored within the user's shopping cart
is made
in this video we'll see how c-sharp
events can be used to facilitate
communication of data between the
loosely coupled razor components within
our application
right let's get started
let's go to our blazer client component
so let's go to the project named
shoponline.web
let's open the i shopping cart service
file
let's create a definition for a c-sharp
event
note that the action type is a delegate
that doesn't return a value
so any method that the relevant delegate
points to will be able to accept the
arguments defined
within the relevant delegate but the
method will not return a value
in our case any method pointed to by
this delegate will accept one argument
of type integer
let's create a definition for a method
that is responsible for raising the
relevant event to subscribed components
if what we are doing here is unclear to
you don't worry
it will become clearer to you as we
develop the code in this video
okay so let's open the shopping cart
service file
let's implement the code for the
interface items that we have just
created
let's implement the code for the raise
event on shopping cart changed method
first we need to check if our event has
any subscribers
we can do this by evaluating the on
shopping cart changed event object
so if the on shopping cart changed
object is not null this means that the
event has subscribers
so if the event has subscribers
we need to write code that raises the
event to those subscribers
we can do this by implementing the
invoke method on the on shopping cart
changed event object
then we can send the appropriate integer
value to each of our subscribers by
passing in the appropriate integer value
to the invoke method
so in the context of our application an
example of a subscriber will be a method
within the cart menu razor component
that we'll create later in this tutorial
when the quantity of the item stored
within the user's shopping cart changes
the event is raised and a custom method
that will be created within the cart
menu razor component will be invoked in
response to the quantity of items stored
within the shopping cart changing
basically when the quantity of the
shopping cart changes the event is
raised and any subscribed methods are
called
this will be clarified with code that
we'll create in a bit
so this event being raised will result
in the new quantity of items stored
within the user's shopping cart
being displayed
from within the cart menu razor
component
let's open the products base dot cs file
let's write code so that an object of
type shopping cart service will be
injected into this razor component at
runtime
so the product razor component is loaded
when a user first launches our
application we want the user to be able
to see how many items are currently
stored within the user's shopping cart
when the application is first loaded
so let's first appropriately call code
on the server to retrieve the shopping
cart items currently stored within the
user's shopping cart
i can feel the comments flowing my way
already
so i think i'll be preemptive and just
say that i'm aware that this may not be
the most performant way of doing this
but i want to focus on events in
relation to razer components in this
tutorial we will be optimizing the code
in later videos
for example by including local storage
functionality
i don't want to make my videos too
convoluted
so this is why i sometimes first create
simplistic code in certain scenarios so
that momentum is gained in the
development of our application
and then as i said we can always
optimize the code in later tutorials
right
let's write code to calculate the number
of items currently stored within the
user's shopping cart
we can then use the shopping cart
service object to raise the appropriate
event
which will in effect send the quantity
of items stored within the user's
shopping cart to any subscribers
so this will result
in the appropriate quantity value being
displayed to the user in the header
section of the layout of our application
let's open the
shoppingcartbase.cs file
so we want our event to be raised each
time the quantity of items stored within
the user's shopping cart changes
let's create a private method named cart
changed
let's rationalize our code a bit
so that the card summary totals private
method is called whenever this card
changed method is called
and we want our events to be raised
whenever the cart changed method is
called
we want our cart changed method to be
called whenever the state of the user's
shopping cart is changed
so let's appropriately call our method
from within the uninitialized async
method
the delete card item underscore click
event handler method and the update qty
cart item underscore click event handler
method
notice that each time we write code to
invoke the cart changed method we are
replacing the call to the cart summary
totals method with the call to our new
cart changed method
because the calculate summary totals
method is now being called from within
the cart changed method
so let's create the code for the cart
menu razer component
this component will be displayed
in the header section of our layout for
our application
so let's create a race component called
cartmenu.razer
within the shared folder
let's write code
so that an object of type i shopping
card service is injected into our cart
menu razor component at runtime
let's open the underscore imports.razer
file and include a using directive that
references the shop online dot web dot
services dot contracts name
space so we are not using inheritance
for this component
so we can instead include code logic for
this razor component within the add code
section of our razer file
this is because our cart menu razor
component is not likely to contain a lot
of code logic so we don't necessarily
need to abstract the code logic into a
separate base class
let's define a variable of type integer
named
shoppingcartitemcount
let's create an override for the razer
component's uninitialized method this
method will be called when our razor
component is first rendered
so we want our razor component to
subscribe
to the event that we created in the
shopping cart service class
to achieve this we can implement this
code
this means that every time the relevant
event is raised the shopping cart
changed method will be run
so we haven't yet implemented code for
the shopping cart changed method so
let's do that
so all we are doing is updating our
shopping cart item count variable with
the quantity value passed into this
method from code that executes to raise
the relevant event
note that we are calling blazers built
in state has changed method here
this is an explicit way of telling
blazer as it were to re-render the
relevant razer component
so we are explicitly telling blazer to
re-render the component after the
shopping cart item count variable
has been assigned a new value from code
that is raising the relevant event
the shopping cart item count
will be used in the ui user interface
code
that we are about to create for
displaying the new quantity of items
stored within the user's shopping cart
so let's write the ui code and this must
exist outside the at code section so we
want a button displayed to the user that
displays a value representing an
up-to-date count of items currently
stored within the user's shopping cart
we also want a user to be able to
navigate to the user's shopping cart
when this button is clicked
in order to prevent possible memory
leaks
we can write code to unsubscribe from
the on shopping cart changed event
so to do this let's implement the i
disposable interface
then we can implement code for the
dispose method to unsubscribe from the
on shopping cart changed event like this
so you can see that the plus equals
operator is used to subscribe to an
event
and the minus equals operator is used to
unsubscribe from an event
let's open the main layout razor
component from within the shared folder
this component is responsible for
displaying the main ui layout of our
application
we can ensure that our cart menu razor
component displays within the header
section
by including the appropriate tag
for our cart menu razer component here
so let's run the code
excellent
so notice that when we are using a
mobile view when running the application
we are not able to see our header menu
item
so let's write code to allow for users
that are using our application in a
mobile view
to be able to see the count of items
currently stored within the user's
shopping cart
and also to be able to navigate to the
user's shopping cart from anywhere
within the application
we can do this by adding an appropriate
menu item to the application's main menu
for when the application is being used
using a mobile view
so let's open the nav menu.razer file
from within the shared directory this
file contains the code responsible for
creating our application's main menu
let's add a new menu item to the main
menu like this
let's write code so that an object of
type i shopping cart service is injected
into this razor component at runtime
in the add code section let's create a
private variable of type integer named
shoppingcartitemscount
let's implement the code to subscribe to
the on shopping cart changed event
let's implement the method
that we want to executed when the on
shopping cart changed event is raised
let's go to the appropriate menu item
code and include the shopping cart item
count variable so that the user is able
to see
from this menu item
how many items are currently stored
within the user's shopping cart
now we only want this menu item to be
shown to users that are using our
application using a mobile view
so we can ensure this by including the d
sm
none bootstrap class within the
appropriate html element that represents
the relevant menu item
lastly let's write code so that before
this razer component is garbage
collected ie before.net frees the memory
taken up by this razor component that
the relevant method within this razor
component is unsubscribed from the on
shopping cart changed event
let's run the code
excellent
so we have now completed all the
functionality that enables a user to add
items to the user's shopping cart as
well as remove items from the user's
shopping cart a user is also able to
update the quantity of products within
the user's shopping cart
so of course no point leaving the
products hanging around in the user's
shopping cart the next logical step is
for a user to purchase the products in
the user's shopping cart
so we are going to create a razor
component in this part of the course
that denotes a checkout facility whereby
the user can purchase the products
within the user's shopping cart
so how do we create a payment facility
so that users can purchase the items in
the user's shopping cart
the answer is we must integrate a
payment gateway into our application
so if we navigate to this website
we can see here some useful information
regarding payment gateways
what is a payment gateway
a payment gateway is a service
that authorizes
and processes debit slash credit card or
paypal payments
for online merchants
and traditional brick and mortar
businesses
a payment gateway facilitates these
transactions
by encrypting sensitive data and
transferring it between a payment portal
a website or a mobile device
and the bank slash front end processor
if we scroll further down this page
we can see a list of the most popular
payment gateway providers
you've probably heard of a few of them
like for example paypal and stripe
paypal stripe square secure pay
worldpay
authorized.net
to checkout.com braintree
i have a business account with paypal so
i'm most familiar with paypal in this
video i'll give you a very basic guide
on how you can integrate the paypal
payment gateway into your application
even though i'm specifically using
paypal the same fundamental principles
will apply for other payment gateways
please see the relevant instructions
provided by your preferred payment
gateway service provider on how you can
integrate your preferred payment gateway
into your applications
the payment gateway service provider
will provide developers with information
on how to integrate the relevant payment
gateway into your application
it's not as difficult as you might think
all of the heavy lifting as it were is
done through the third party payment
gateway
so this tutorial is not a definitive or
comprehensive guide on how to integrate
a payment gateway into your application
but it will hopefully give you a very
good idea of how to integrate a payment
gateway into your applications
it all depends on your application's
requirement on how you go about
implementing relevant payment gateway
integration functionality in your
applications
let me first present a brief disclaimer
before we start this tutorial
this is not a definitive guide
on integrating a payment gateway into
your application
this is certainly not a final e-commerce
solution
the purpose of this tutorial
serves to give you a basic idea
of how you are able to integrate a
payment gateway into a blazer
webassembly application
if you wish to create an application
that uses a payment gateway in a live
environment you'll need to research
relevant information provided by your
preferred payment gateway provider in
order to gain a thorough understanding
of how to create an e-commerce solution
using the relevant payment gateway
right let's get started
let's create a razor component named
checkout.razer within the pages folder
let's create a c-sharp class named
checkoutbase.cs within the pages folder
let's write code to ensure that the
checkout razer component inherits from
the checkout base class
as the name of our razer component
suggests a user will navigate to this
razor component in order to purchase the
items within the user's shopping cart
paypal makes it easy for us to integrate
the payment gateway functionality within
our applications by providing us with
sample html and javascript code
in order to copy the relevant html and
javascript code let's navigate to this
paypal web page
if we scroll further down the page
paypal presents us with a few options
i'm going to use the first option here
let's click the start setup button
let's select the variable price list
item here
let's select the desktop option here
then to copy the relevant javascript and
html code we can click the copy code
button here
let's navigate to our index.html page
and paste the html and javascript code
currently stored within our clipboards
here
you can see here we have a javascript
function named init paypal button
this method contains callback methods
like for example create order and on
approved
the create order method is called by
paypal when an order is created
and the on approved method is called
after the relevant order has been
approved by paypal
note that within the on approved method
there is code that logs information
about the order which is sent back from
paypal after an order has been approved
to the browser console window the
relevant information is sent back from
paypal regarding the relevant order
after the order has been approved by
paypal
so this gives us an idea of how our code
integrates with paypal
we also have a script tag here that
references a script file at a specific
paypal location
the way in which we are able to link a
paypal account to our application is
through this client dash id parameter
here
at the moment we only have a placeholder
value for the client dash id parameter
i'll demonstrate a bit later
how we are able to generate a valid
client id value that we can paste over
this placeholder value here
i'll demonstrate this a bit later
we have this html code here that
contains various fields and a
placeholder for the relevant payment
gateway related buttons that the user
can use to start the payment process
the user will be able to pay using a
valid debit or credit card by clicking
this button or if the user has a valid
paypal account the user can use the
user's paypal account by clicking this
button
for a particular integration requirement
we can tailor the sample code to our
needs
so we are going to simplify the code
here and remove code that is superfluous
in relation to our particular
requirement
so let's say
that for a particular integration
requirement
we only need the description field and
the amount field
so we can delete the javascript code
from the init paypal button method here
that references the html elements
denoting the fields that we don't need
we don't need this code here so let's
delete it
we don't need this code because it is
code used for validating user input
code within our application will control
what is entered into the appropriate
fields namely the amount field and the
description field
therefore we don't need any user
validation related code
in the on init method
there is a lot of code relevant to user
validation that we don't need
let's delete the honornet method
within the onclick method we only need
this code here that references the
values that will be inserted into the
amount and description fields at an
appropriate time by certain code within
our application so let's copy the
relevant code from the onclick method
here
let's paste it into the create order
method here
then we can simply delete the onclick
method
you can see here in the on approved
method we have code here that logs order
information to the user's browser
console window this information is sent
back from paypal once a user's order has
been approved by paypal and contains
details about the user's order we'll
examine the order information later when
we test our code
you can see here that the sample code
that we copied from paypal includes a
call
to the init paypal button javascript
method
we want to control when the init paypal
button method is invoked
we'll implement the code to call the
init paypal button method
using c-sharp code and blaze's
javascript interoperability feature from
within the checkout razer component in a
bit
so let's remove the call to the init
paypal button from the index.html file
let's cut this html code here
and paste it into our checkout.razer
file
this will allow the paypal buttons to be
available to the user when the user
invokes the checkout raiser component
for our particular requirement let's say
that all we are interested in is the
description field and the amount field
so let's remove the html elements that
we don't need
for the implementation of our
integration code with paypal
we don't need the html elements
that label the relevant fields
because we are going to make the amount
field and description field hidden text
fields
we don't want the user to enter any
payment information we are going to
control the values that are inserted
into these fields through c-sharp code
that we'll implement in a bit
we need this div element here because
this tells paypal as it were
where we want the relevant paypal
gateway related buttons placed within
our ui
so
for our requirement
we don't want these fields to be visible
to the user
so let's make these fields hidden text
fields
so let's create the code for the
checkout base.cs class
we are going to want to call
the init paypal button javascript method
that resides within our index.html file
from within the checkoutbase.cs class so
we need to write code that ensures that
an object of type rjsruntime
is injected into our checkoutrazor
component at runtime
this is so that we can utilize blaze's
javascript interoperability feature to
call the init paypal button javascript
method
that we copied from the relevant paypal
web page earlier
we'll write the code to call this
javascript method in a bit
we need to reference the collection of
shopping cart items
so let's create a property of type i
enumerable that is strongly typed with
the cart item dto type
let's create a property named total qty
let's create a property named payment
description
let's create a property named payment
amount
let's create code to bind the paypal
related hidden text fields we have
implemented within the checkout.razer
file
to their counterpart properties by using
blazers at bind syntax
so this means that every time relevant
property values change
laser will automatically update their
counterpart input fields
i.e the input fields that contain the
relevant at bind syntax in the
checkout.racer file
the payment description and payment
amount properties will be bound to the
input fields implemented within the
checkout.racer file
so this is one of the aspects involved
in integrating our application with
paypal
we can communicate the total payment
amount to paypal through the payment
amount property and we can communicate
whatever payment description we want by
updating the payment description
property
the javascript within the init paypal
button method references the fields that
we have implemented using hidden text
fields in the checkout.razer file i.e
the amount field and the description
field
the fields are bound to their
counterpart properties within the
checkout base class
we can use this description field to
uniquely identify a particular payment
there are of course many different ways
to implement this type of functionality
i've chosen this way for the sake of the
example in the interests of keeping the
example simple i.e for teaching purposes
when we run the code and create a test
order once our order is approved by
paypal we'll be able to inspect the data
within our browser's console window
which is the data sent back from paypal
after our order has been approved
we'll see that one of the fields
contains our unique description value
we want an object of type i shopping
cart service to be injected into our
checkout raiser component at run time so
let's create a property of type i
shopping cart service and ensure that it
is decorated with the inject attribute
let's override the uninitialized async
method
let's implement code to retrieve the
user's shopping cart items
we'll look at code in a later tutorial
whereby we can use local storage
functionality so that we don't have to
make so many calls to the server
we can use local storage to improve
performance but we'll write this code in
a later tutorial
so i'm writing code to create a new good
here
so that we can use this good value to
uniquely identify a particular order
let's assign the total payment amount to
the payment amount property
let's assign the total quantity
to the total qty property
let's create an identifier field so that
we can uniquely identify a particular
order as i said earlier
i'm just doing this for the sake of this
example
it is up to the developer to modify the
appropriate code so that it is adapted
appropriately in relation to the
developer's particular requirement
so let's include an o for order followed
by the user's id
and then followed by the unique guide
value within the payment description
field
let's override the on after render async
method this method is called in response
to the occurrence of a blazer lifecycle
event that occurs after the relevant
razer component is rendered
we can use the first render argument
passed to this method to ensure that our
code within this method is only fired
once after our razor component is first
rendered
so if first render is true
we want code to execute that uses our js
object to call the init paypal button
javascript method
so you can see how we are integrating
our checkout razer component
with the sample javascript code that we
included within the index.html file this
is of course the sample code we copied
from paypal
so as to perform our integration with
their payment gateway
so the next step is to generate the
client id
whereby we can link our paypal account
to our application
so we need to do this through paypal
note that you are able to follow along
with the next part of this tutorial even
if you just have a personal account with
paypal
you will however need a business account
with paypal if you wish to go live
with the paypal payment gateway
functionality
paypal provides a sandbox feature that
we can use for development and testing
purposes but as i said if you wish to go
live you'll need a paypal business
account for instructions on how to
create a paypal business account please
navigate to this url
so assuming you have a paypal account as
stated you are still able to follow
along even if you just have a personal
account and you don't have a business
account
let's log in to paypal
then let's click the developer menu
option here
so that we can use the sandbox feature
to implement the server side part of the
integration functionality so that we can
integrate the paypal payment gateway
into our application
you can then navigate to the dashboard
like this
you can see here you have two options
one for sandbox and the other for live
we are going to use the sandbox facility
if you want to go live with your paypal
payment gateway you would use the live
facility
as discussed you will need a paypal
business account before you are able to
go live with the paypal payment gateway
so to create the server side
functionality that we need in order to
integrate the paypal payment gateway
into our application click the create
app button
let's give the app a sensible name
and then create the app like this
we now have this client id generated for
us
and this is the key to how we can
associate our client-side integration
with our paypal account
so let's copy this client id value to
our clipboards
let's remain logged into paypal
and let's appropriately paste the
relevant client id value to our
index.html file here for the client-id
parameter
great
while we are here let's remove the
enable dash funding parameter here
let's go back to paypal
so for testing purposes paypal allows us
to generate mock credit card details
when we test our code we are going to
use the generated mock credit card
details to make a test payment
we can generate mock credit card details
by clicking the credit card generator
menu option here
and then i'm going to select the united
kingdom as my country first
and then to generate the mock credit
card details we can press the generate
credit card button here
so let's copy the relevant mock credit
card details and save them somewhere so
that we can access them a little bit
later when we test our application
before we test the code let's make sure
that we can navigate from our shopping
cart razor component
to our checkout component so to do this
let's appropriately update the code
within our
shoppingcart.razer file
then we must also ensure
that we have an appropriate at page
directive at the top of our
checkout.racer file
a user needs to be able to navigate
directly to the checkout raiser
component
so we must include appropriate root
template information following the add
page directive
and now we should be able to make a test
payment through our application
let's run the code
let's add some items to our shopping
cart
let's proceed to check out
let's appropriately enter our mock
credit card details along with some
appropriate made up data regarding
personal information like address and
phone number
excellent
now if we press f12
within our chrome browsers
we can see the data sent back from
paypal
in the on approved callback method
defined within the init paypal button
method we have code to log data sent
back from paypal after an approved order
has been made
we could implement code that extracts
the relevant data from the returned data
from paypal and update our application's
database in an appropriate way depending
on our requirement
that functionality is beyond the scope
of this course but hopefully this gives
you a good enough insight
of how to integrate the paypal
functionality into your application but
please read the relevant developer
related information provided by your
preferred payment gateway service
provider for information on how to
create relevant integration
functionality that best suits your
requirement
and you can see here our custom
description value
that we created earlier in code
has been sent back from paypal along
with the other order information
which contains the user id value
and a guide value that our code
generates for each order that is sent to
paypal
so let's finish the code for our
checkout raiser component
let's say that we want to display a
summary of items that the user is
purchasing on the checkout ui
next to the paypal buttons
so let's write the code for this
please note this code can be copied from
the relevant github repository i have
included the location of the relevant
github repository below in the
description
let's test the code
excellent
this is the 10th part and the
penultimate video in a video series
dedicated to building a shopping cart
application on net 6.
so we are nearly finished building our
shopping cart application
in this video we are going to create
functionality so that a user can filter
the products in our stores product
catalog
by product category
we will write codes to query our
database for all the product categories
within our database and display them as
menu items in the main menu contained
within the sidebar section of our ui
when the user clicks one of the menu
items denoting a product category
data representing the products related
to that category will be appropriately
displayed to the user
right let's get started
so in the first part of this course we
created our database through ef core
code first migrations a requirement to
update the databases seed data or
structure may arise for example due to a
decision to include new functionality
within the application or perhaps just
to correct a minor mistake made when the
database was first created and seeded
with data
through ef core code first migrations we
have the agility that we need to make
appropriate adjustments to our database
during the development and testing
phases of our application
so before we start writing code we need
to address a database related
requirement
we need to add a new column to the
product categories database table
where we can store relevant css code
that denotes an icon used to represent a
product category
we are of course going to use ef core
code first migrations to address this
requirement
so let's first update the product
category entity class to include a new
string property
and let's appropriately name our new
property icon css
we are going to need an appropriate dto
data transfer object to house the data
that we send back to the client for when
a client makes a request to the server
for a collection of product category
data
so let's go to the shoponline.models
project and create an appropriate class
to represent the relevant dto
let's go back to the shoponline.api
project
before we generate the relevant
migration code let's open the shop
online dbcontext class and update the
relevant code for seeding our database
within the onmodelcreating method
so here we are including relevant font
awesome css classes within the new field
named icon css
these classes will be appropriately
referenced within our code to render
appropriate icon images for each of the
relevant product categories
so let's create our migration
and give it a sensible name
great
let's look at the migration code that we
have just generated
great
let's run our migration through the
update dash database command
excellent
so let's go to our shoponline.api
project
so if we look at the product repository
class
we can see that we have already written
the code for returning a collection of
product category objects
we need to expose this functionality to
the relevant clients
so to do this let's create an
appropriate action method within the
product controller class
let's create an extension method to
convert the collection of product
category objects to a collection of
product category dto objects
this may seem like a pointless exercise
because the shape of the product
category class is exactly the same as
the shape of the product category dto
class
it is important to understand that even
though this step may seem unnecessary
that we are doing this due to design
best practices
why is this the design best practice
in the future a new requirement may
arise for example where a client may
require additional data to be returned
from the relevant action method
we want to maintain a clear separation
of concerns between the dto classes and
the corresponding entity classes
the reason for this is that the relevant
dto classes can evolve independently
from the relevant entity classes if
required without affecting their
counterpart entity classes
so a dto class can for example be
extended without affecting its
counterpart entity class
let's finish off the code for our action
method
great
so let's go to the shoponline.web
project and write the calling client
code for retrieving a collection of
product category data
let's create the relevant service code
let's add an appropriate method
definition to the i product service
interface
let's implement the code for the
interface that we have just created
so our code in this method is
appropriately requesting a collection of
objects of type product category dto
from the server great
let's create a razor component that will
be responsible for outputting the
product categories as menu items inside
our blazer applications main menu that
resides within the sidebar section of
our applications ui
so within the shared directory let's
create a razor component named product
categories nav menu
let's create a class named product
categories nav menu base
let's write code so that an object of
type i product service
is injected into our razor component at
run time
let's create a property of type i
enumerable that is strongly typed with
the product category dto type
let's create a string property named
error message
let's override the uninitialized async
method
let's create code within the
uninitialized async method that
retrieves a collection of objects of
type product category dto from the
server and assigns the returned
collection to the product category dtos
property
great
let's implement the code for the product
categories nav menu razer file
so we need to create a using directive
that references the shoponline.web.pages
namespace so let's add the appropriate
using directive to the underscore
imports.razer file
we are adding this using directive
because we are going to add appropriate
tags
to the product categories nav menu razer
file that reference relevant child razor
components that have been added to the
pages directory
for example
the display spinner child razor
component
so notice that we are creating a link
that contains a category id parameter
we'll later write code that uses this
parameter value to query the server for
a collection of product data that is
related to a particular category denoted
by the relevant category id value
so we haven't yet written the code for
the products by category raiser
component
we'll write the code for this razor
component a bit later
this razor component will contain code
for displaying a collection of objects
of type product dto
that are related to the category id
value
that will be passed as a parameter to
the products by category razor component
so the next step is to reference our new
razor component from within the razer
component that contains the main menu
that appears to the user in the sidebar
of the ui
so let's add the appropriate tag to
reference our product categories nav
menu razor component
let's run the code
and we can see that our product
categories are now appearing as menu
items within the sidebar
however
as you can see the style of the product
category menu items are different from
the home menu item
because the codes that produces the
category menu item is contained within a
different razor component
so to solve this i'm simply going to
copy the css code from the
navmenu.razer.css file and paste it into
a new css file that we must name product
categories nav menu dot razer dot css
so this will result in the product
category menu items being styled like
the home menu item
so we are flagrantly violating the
principle of dry don't repeat yourself
here
i'm doing this deliberately to keep up
the momentum and creating the code for
this application so that i can
effectively keep the focus on the
aspects that are the subject of this
part of the course
you can of course centralize the css
code for the menu items in adherence
with the principle of dry however for
the reasons i've just explained i won't
address this issue in this part of the
course
great
so let's move on to create the code for
filtering the products by category
let's go back to the shoponline.api
project
let's go to the i product repository
interface
let's create a new method definition
within the i product repository
interface
the code that we'll implement for this
method will be responsible for
retrieving a collection of product data
that is related to a particular product
category
so let's implement the code for the
method that we have just defined within
the product repository class
let's create an appropriate action
method to expose this functionality to
calling client code
great
right let's go back to the
shoponline.web project and implement the
service related code regarding the
functionality for retrieving product
data related to a particular category id
let's open the i product service
interface
and create an appropriate method
definition
let's implement the code logic for the
method definition that we have just
created
so here we are appropriately requesting
a collection of objects of type products
dto
that are related to a particular product
category
right let's create a razor component
responsible for displaying the product
data filtered by category on the ui
let's name this razor component products
by category.razer
let's create a class named products by
category base
let's implement the code for the
products by category base class
firstly let's create a property that
represents a parameter that will be
passed into this razor component
the value passed into this category id
parameter will be an appropriate
category id value
note that we are able to declare that a
property represents a parameter
by decorating the relevant property with
the parameter attribute
let's create the other necessary
properties for our razor component
so we want our collection of products to
be retrieved for a particular category
only when the category id parameter is
set
so we can do this by implementing our
code within a method that is called by
blazer in response to a life cycle event
occurring
when our parameter value is set
so to achieve this we are overriding a
built-in blazer method named on
parameters set async
so let's write the code within the on
parameters set async method
our code simply retrieves the
appropriate products data from the
server based on the value passed into
our category id parameter
let's write the appropriate ui code
within the products by category.razer
file
so let's first use the add page
directive to appropriately declare the
relevant root template information for
our products by category razer component
let's write code to inherit from the
products by category base class
let's implement the code logic
so as you can see
we can reuse our display products razor
component
that we created in a previous part of
this course to display the relevant
products data to the user
let's run the code
excellent
so you can see that our product category
menu items appear differently when
compared to the home menu item
so let's fix this in code so that our
menu items are displayed in a consistent
way to the user
great
let's finish off by adding an
appropriate logo for our application
excellent
i hope you have enjoyed this video i
look forward to presenting the final
video in this series
where we'll optimize our code to
potentially create better performance
for our application
hi and welcome i'm gavin lon
this is the 11th and final part in a
series of videos dedicated to building a
shopping cart application using blazer
web assembly and web api on net six
so we have now built our basic shopping
cart application
but is software ever really 100 complete
at points there may be bug fixes to make
we may need to upgrade our application
with the latest technologies
a requirement may arise to improve the
overall performance of the application
there may be parts of the application
where ux user experience can be enhanced
in this video we are going to look
specifically at how we can improve the
performance of our application
by optimizing our code
there are two areas where we can
potentially enhance the performance of
our application
item number one
in the web api component we are
currently making two separate queries to
the database when retrieving product
data
our code is returning both product data
and product category data to the calling
client
to do this we are currently calling two
separate methods in the product
repository class
one for retrieving details about the
products from the product database table
and the other for retrieving details
about the product categories from the
product categories database table
so in this video to potentially enhance
performance we are going to retrieve the
product and category details through one
query to the database instead of two
the other area where we can improve
performance is by using local storage
within the blazer component to store
both the product data and shopping cart
data so that when our application needs
to retrieve relevant product data or
shopping cart data
our code can retrieve the relevant
information from local storage i.e data
stored on the client within the user's
browser as opposed to making a trip as
it were to the server every time the
relevant data needs to be retrieved
so basically the travel time and
retrieving the relevant data can be
shortened in certain scenarios the data
can be retrieved on the client instead
of the server
for content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so as to be notified of
future content
if you like this video please hit the
like button and please feel free to
share this video with anyone you feel
may benefit from its content
so let's attack the first item let's go
to the shoponline.api project
let's optimize the code on the server
where we can make one query to the
database to retrieve both product
information and related product category
information rather than use two separate
queries for this purpose
so the first step is that we need to
modify the class representing the
product entity
so we must first add a public property
to the product class that is of type
product category
let's add the foreign key attribute to
our new product category property we can
then pass an appropriate string value to
the foreign key attribute
that is used for declaring which
property in the product class must be
used for joining the product entity to
the product category entity so this code
will indicate to ef core as it were how
we want to join the product entity to
the product category entity
let's go to the product repository class
and first modify the get item method to
appropriately join the product entity to
the product category entity in the
relevant link query
so to do this we can use the include
method like this
we are establishing the join between the
two entities through this lambda
expression
notice the product category property
that we recently created within the
product
class for this query we only want to
retrieve one item
so we can use the single or default
async method to filter the product data
based on the relevant product id passed
to this method
then for the get items method the code
is similar to the get item method
but for the get items method we wish to
return all the products that are
currently stored in the products
database table with the related product
category information
to the calling code
so we of course don't need to filter the
data
so that means we don't need to use a
method like the single or default async
method in this query
then the last method that we need to
appropriately modify is the get items by
category method
if we open the product controller class
we can see that we can now simplify the
code here but first we need to
appropriately update the relevant
extension methods responsible for
converting objects of type product to
objects of type product dto
so let's first update the extension
method that converts an individual
product to type product dto
great
then let's update the conversion
extension method that converts a
collection of objects of type product to
a collection of objects of type product
dto
great
we can now update the relevant action
methods accordingly
we no longer need to query for the
category items in a separate query that
we are using here to get a collection of
category items
so we've potentially improved
performance of the server-side code
through an appropriate code optimization
exercise
we are only dealing with a small amount
of data so the performance improvement
would probably be negligible
but if we were dealing with large
amounts of data the performance
improvement would be more significant
so let's look at the second way that we
can improve the performance of our
application
the second way that we can improve the
performance of our application involves
an update to our blazer component
so let's go to the shoponline.web
project
let's see how we can reduce the number
of trips to the server we are currently
making for retrieving relevant product
and shopping cart data
through the use of local storage
so we could use javascript and blazer's
javascript interoperability feature and
write our own local storage
functionality
it turns out though we don't need to go
to this kind of trouble because someone
has already made available a new get
package that contains the local storage
functionality we need
so let's invoke the nuget package
manager window
let's search for local storage
and this is the package we want to
install
so let's install the
blazered.localstorage nuget package
for more details regarding local storage
please navigate to this url
basically the javascript local storage
object allows you to save key value
pairs in the browser
note the local storage object stores
data with no expiration date the data is
not deleted when the browser is closed
and are available for future sessions
so the local storage functionality
provided to us within the
blazid.localstorage nuget package
abstracts the javascript code for
managing local storage
so we don't need to write the relevant
javascript code ourselves
we are now going to create two services
to encapsulate our local storage
functionality so let's first create an
interface named i manage products local
storage service
let's create two method definitions like
this
let's create an appropriate method
definition for a method named get
collection
let's create an appropriate method
definition for a method named remove
collection
let's create an appropriate service
class to implement the methods defined
within the interface we have just
created
let's create a constructor whereby we
indicate that we want an object of type
i local storage service and an object of
type i product service injected into our
constructor at run time
note that the i local storage service
type is a type provided by the
blazer.localstorage nuget package that
we have now installed
so this type will be used to implement
the necessary local storage
functionality
let's create a private method named ad
collection
this method simply retrieves the product
data from the server
and saves the relevant product data in
the user's browser using local storage
okay let's create a string constant to
store the key that will be used to
identify the relevant value
in this case the relevant value is a
serialized collection of objects of type
product dto
let's implement the code for the get
collection method
so this method first tries to retrieve
the relevance data from local storage
if the relevant data does not exist in
local storage we can call the add
collection private method to retrieve
the relevant data from the server and
save the relevant data to the user's
browser using local storage
the remove collection method simply
removes the relevant data stored within
the user's browser using local storage
right let's create an interface within
the contracts folder named i manage cart
items local storage service
let's create an appropriate method
definition for a method named get
collection
let's create an appropriate method
definition for a method named save
collection
let's create an appropriate method
definition for a method named remove
collection
right let's implement the relevant code
for the interface that we have just
created
so let's first create a class named
manage cart items local storage service
let's create a constructor whereby we
indicate that we want an object of type
i local storage service and an object of
type i shopping cart service injected
into our constructor at runtime
let's create a constant to store the key
that will be used to identify the
relevant items stored using local
storage the local storage item in this
case will be a serialized collection of
card item dto objects
let's create a private method named add
collection
this method simply retrieves relevant
data from the server and appropriately
saves the data to local storage
this method attempts to retrieve the
relevant data from local storage if the
relevant data does not exist in local
storage the code retrieves the relevant
data from the server and appropriately
saves the relevant data to local storage
let's implement the code for the remove
collection method which involves
appropriately deleting a collection of
objects of type cart item dto from local
storage
notice that the key constant is used to
identify the relevant local storage item
let's implement the code for the save
collection method which involves
appropriately saving a collection of
objects of type cart item dto to local
storage
so we haven't yet registered the ilocal
storage service type provided in the
blazer.localstorage package with the
dependency injection system
so let's open our program.cs file
and apply the code to register the
ilocalstorage service type for
dependency injection
so we can use the add blazer local
storage extension method for this
purpose
we must then also register our two new
service classes that we have created to
abstract the relevant local storage
functionality with the dependency
injection system
so let's now implement the relevant
local storage functionality within the
relevant razor components in order to
hopefully increase the performance of
our blazer component
let's open the products base class
this is the base class for the razor
component that first loads when our
application is first launched
let's create the code to ensure
that our two local storage services are
injected into this razor component
let's say that when the product's razor
component is loaded we want to clear the
relevant local storage items from local
storage
this will force our code to retrieve the
relevant data from the server at this
stage
then subsequently we want the relevant
data retrieved from local storage to
enhance performance
so let's create a private method named
clear local storage and use the relevant
functionality we have created within the
relevant services to remove the relevant
data from local storage
let's call this method from within the
uninitialized async method
then instead of going straight to the
server for our data let's use the
appropriate local storage service object
to first check to see if the relevant
data resides within local storage
of course in this case we are clearing
the data before this method is called
which will force our code to retrieve
the data from the server
however our code will subsequently save
the data retrieved from the server to
local storage which means that when
other razer components retrieve the
relevant data
the data will be retrieved from local
storage on the client side which means
an unnecessary trip to the server will
be avoided
so this gives us an idea of how we are
able to increase performance of our
application using local storage
we can also use our manage cart items
local storage service object
to retrieve any cart item data that may
be saved to the user's shopping cart
like this
so in this case this code will retrieve
the relevant data from the server and
save the data to local storage
any data retrieval of items within the
user's shopping cart can then be done
from local storage and therefore trips
to the server are saved and the
performance of our application is
potentially enhanced
let's appropriately update the shopping
cart razor component
let's write the code so that an object
of type i manage card items local
storage service is injected into this
razor component at runtime
in the uninitialized async method let's
replace the code that retrieves the
relevant cart item data from the server
to get the relevant data from local
storage
when a user updates the quantity of a
particular item saved within the user's
shopping cart we must update the
relevant local storage item
this is because of course the relevant
shopping cart has now changed
we can appropriately implement the safe
collection method for this purpose
we must also use the appropriate local
storage service to implement the code to
update the relevant local storage item
when a user removes an item from the
user's shopping cart
let's implement the relevant local
storage related code for the product
details razer component
so this component is responsible for
displaying details for a particular
product
this razer component also contains
functionality for adding a product to
the user's shopping cart
let's first create a private property to
reference the shopping cart items
collection here because when the user
adds a product to the user's shopping
cart we want our code to update the
relevant local storage item
we no longer only want the code to
update the relevant shopping cart on the
server we need to keep the client side
local storage data up to date as well
so let's first write code to update our
shopping cart item's private property
with data retrieved from local storage
within the uninitialized async method so
within the method responsible for adding
a new item to the user's shopping cart
we need to write code that not only
updates the data on the server but also
updates the relevant local storage item
so we can implement the desired
functionality in code like this
we can also now implement code that gets
data for an individual product from
local storage
great
let's appropriately update the products
by category razor component to include
local storage functionality
let's write code so that an object of
type image products local storage
service will be injected into this razor
component at runtime
let's write a private method
so that the products filtered by
category id are retrieved from local
storage
let's appropriately call our new private
method from within the on parameters set
async method
lastly let's appropriately update the
checkout razer component with our local
storage functionality
great let's run the code
excellent
that definitely seems to have made a
positive difference to the performance
of our shopping cart application
if you've made it to the end of this
course well done
you have learned quite a lot about laser
web assembly and web api
we have also learned how to create a
basic spy application where the vast
majority of the code is implemented
using c-sharp
i hope you have enjoyed going through
this course as much as i enjoyed
creating it
for content like this and much more
please consider subscribing and please
ring the bell so as to be notified of
future content
if you liked this video please hit the
like button and please feel free to
share this video with anyone you feel
may benefit from its content
i really enjoy engaging with you in the
comments section so please feel free to
leave a comment
the latest code can be found on github a
link to the relevant repository has been
included below in the description
thank you and take care